Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und ich begrüße alle zur Ausgabe sechsundneunzig.
UKW und äh ja regelmäßige Hörerinnen und Hörer werden es schon ahnen. Es geht wieder mal um die Ukrainerinnen
Podcast hat sich ja jetzt als äh Weltkrisenbegleiter etabliert, also muss man die Krise auch begleiten, solange sie noch anhält, solange sie noch warm ist.
Und bisher habe ich ja immer mit Pavel gesprochen, aber heute machen wir mal einen Schritt zur Seite und äh stattdessen begrüße ich Enno Eno Lenze. Hallo Enno.
Hallo, mir fällt bei dieser Anmoderation ein, wir haben jetzt schon die dritte Krise miteinander. Äh wir hatten Kurdistan.
Ja, genau.
Und Hongkong, wenn man das äh also so als ja Krise ist das schon irgendwie.
Es war ganz lustig, als es sich schon auch abzeichnete so mit der Ukraine. Da hatte ich irgendwie eigentlich schon das Telefon so in der Hand äh gedanklich und dachte so, hm, da braut sich doch was zusammen, vielleicht mal mit innovieren, weil ich dann auch gesehen habe, dass du das thematisiert hast, obwohl ja eigentlich,
Das Gebiet bisher gar nicht so auf deiner internationalen Landkarte war, oder?
Gar nicht. Also ich meine, ich kannte die Existenz und ich kenne zwei Leute da und da hört es so auf.
Ja und du bist auch Westkind und von daher hast du auch nicht so diesen Ost.
Noch mehr. Also ich bin ich bin zwar Westkinder, ich bin ja in Ostafrika aufgewachsen, also äh so bis die Mauer fiel, war ich quasi nicht in Deutschland. Also das ist halt kurz vorher, also so noch weiter weg von der ganzen komischen Sache.
Mhm. Genau, die komische Sache, also Osteuropa. Ähm
Ja, also äh ist für uns äh oder für viele von uns, das gilt natürlich jetzt äh für die Leute, die so aus der DDR äh äh stammen oder oder da noch quasi
mitgenommen wurden, ihre Schulzeit verlebt haben. Äh für die ist es,
anders, glaube ich. Allein schon mal russisch gelernt zu haben, all diese äh Dinge erzeugt einfach eine gewisse Nähe, die wir äh nicht haben. Aber wie wie hast du dich denn dann dem,
genährt dem Thema.
Also ich meine zum einen habe ich ja immer gedacht, okay, irgendwie die ganze Geschichte mit äh damals auf dem Mai dann die Proteste und mit der Krim und so. Das ist ja äh also man befasst sich ja mit, wenn man so normaler Medien konsumierender Mensch ist,
und äh zum anderen war dann auch ganz trivial,
Mich hat halt interessiert, wie genau funktioniert denn das jetzt rechtlich mit der Krim und also diese ganzen komischen Fragen, die man sich nie im Leben gestellt hat,
und äh dann kommt dazu, ich kenne Leute, die in der Ukraine wohnen, aber das war halt nie ein,
oder die daherkommen, mit denen habe ich in Dubai gearbeitet, das war nie ein Thema. Also hallo, ich bin aus Deutschland. Hallo, ich bin aus der Ukraine. Okay, ihr habt dieses Ding mit der Krim, ja, ist weit weg, okay. Also so es war nicht nicht das beherrschende Thema.
Und,
im Dezember hat mich ein Freund gefragt ob ich mit in den Donbass will der baut und entwickelt und vertreibt gepanzerte Fahrzeuge an Regierungen und Spezialeinheiten und so ein Kram,
Und das heißt, im Prinzip interessieren uns immer die gleichen Punkte auf der Welt aus unterschiedlichen Gründen, also so er hat da seine Kunden,
Und ich will wissen, was los ist und deswegen reisen wir halt zusammen,
Dann waren wir in Gramatursk. Ähm das ist so zwischen Kiew und Doniac so ganz ganz vage, dass man so eine Idee hat, wo es ist so ein Ort,
Und es war im Dezember, ich glaube das langweiligste, was ich im Leben gesehen habe. Also es war theoretisch, dicht an der Kampflinie da im Donbass und in der Praxis war da absolut gar nix.
Also man muss dazu sagen, Gramatus ist deutlich näher jetzt an an Donalds und Luhansk,
äh als an Kiew, also Kiew ist ja quasi in der Mitte des Landes. Dann kommt erstmal äh und dann beginnt halt äh eigentlich erst diese ganze Donbass Region, wo ja Kramatos selber auch dazugehört.
Also ist nur der nicht von den Russen besetzte Teil gewesen.
Genau und äh und da war's dann so ja klar, dann befasst man sich mehr mit und so wie immer, man liest die Wikipedia Seite und sagt, ah,
Das kleine Atomungungungunglück irgendwie in einem Plattenbau haben sie irgendwie radioaktive Strahlung festgestellt und also so man denkt, okay, okay, so aus sozusagen aus
westdeutscher Sicht sowjetbaukunst, also mit ein bisschen Strahlung drin, okay, äh so die üblichen Klischees, die man da erwartet und.
Aber auch da war es so, ja, es gab halt diesen Truppenaufbau seit Jahren und ich fand's auch so ein bisschen,
Immer wenn ich gefragt wurde, weil du kennst das ja, wenn man in irgendeiner Stadt war, ist man der Experte. Also haben mich Leute sagen, ah du warst in der Ukraine im Dom, warst, boah, du bist der Experte. Ja.
Wie ist das jetzt? Ich habe auch im im Dezember und also bis kurz bevor es losging gesagt,
mein Gefühl, ohne dass ich darauf wetten würde ist, dass Putin blöfft. Also klar, hochprofessionell, mit viel Aufwand, es muss ja echt aussehen.
Ich habe die ganze Zeit gedacht, der kann nicht so blöd sein, also der weiß doch, dass die Folgen exorbitant äh katastrophal für ihn sind, egal wie's ausgeht.
Äh also weswegen ich auch denke, ich habe dann zwar angefangen mich mit dem ganzen Thema auch mehr und mehr zu beschäftigen, aber je mehr ich mich mit beschäftigt habe, desto mehr dachte ich,
Bin ich zu blöd oder dass Putin hier zu blöd? Das ergibt doch von vorne bis hinten keinen Sinn, die Story. Und ich glaube, das war auch so ermüdend daran, dass man sagt, das das hat doch eigentlich keinen Anfang, kein Ende die Story und in der Mitte keinen Sinn. Also so ich find's,
schwierig sich mit so Themen zu beschäftigen, wo man denkt, was worum geht's hier oder was was ist der Punkt.
Also hier kam es sozusagen alles etwas,
Verfahren und unklar vor, ne? Ich meine, so so ging's wahrscheinlich vielen und äh mir sicherlich auch und diese ganze Situation da im Donbass und natürlich dann auch nach der Übernahme der Krim
überhaupt generell Ukraine war ja auch immer sehr schwer einzuschätzen glaube ich für uns eben weil da auch so ein komischer ähm,
Also erstmal so diese diese sprachliche Teilung des Landes, die er da einfach vorhergibt, einfach einen russischsprachigen Teil und einen ukrainischen und ähm,
Der eine Teil wählt so, der andere wählt so, man könnte nie so richtig einschätzen, ja wo steht ihr denn äh jetzt eigentlich? Seid ihr also Teil dieser russischen Sphäre nur irgendwie mit anderen Farben drauf?
Oder was man ja auch liest und wahrgenommen hat so,
seid ihr irgendwie auch so Europa. Das immer immer sehr schwer einzuschätzen gewesen und ich denke, es hat sich aber auch erst jetzt mit diesem Krieg wirklich,
entschieden. Also das ist so wirklich äh.
Wirklich so Schrödingers Katze in gewisser Hinsicht, ne? Also es war immer irgendwie weder das eine noch das andere oder beides irgendwie gleichzeitig und er ist jetzt wo äh quasi die.
Die Büchse der Pandora auch wirklich mal geöffnet wurde, weiß man halt, wie's aussieht.
Wissen hat's mich erinnert an die Türkei, wo ja mal diese EU-Aufnahmegespräche liefen oder nicht. Und klar, äh wir haben viele Menschen, die hier leben, die irgendwie aus der Türkei kommen oder verwandelt haben oder wie auch immer und auf der anderen Seite ist es ein Urlaubsland für Deutsche,
aber eigentlich, so von der aufn ersten Blick würde man sagen, ah es ist doch nicht richtig Europa. Das ist doch arabische Welt ja auch nicht, also er sagt, nee, da passt nicht in Russland, also so was was treibt ihr da in der Mitte? Also ihr seid so,
Gehört nicht zur arabischen Welt, okay, aber so richtig Europa nicht, Russland nicht, zum Meer gehört ihr auch nicht, Fische sind's auch nicht, also was was macht ihr da? Daran hat mich das so ein bisschen erinnert, so dass man so sagt, na ja also so halb halb,
Also man kennt's, aber man befasst sich auch eigentlich nicht mit. Also ich kenne glaube ich keinen Menschen, der sich vor 2014 groß so in meiner Bubble mit Ukraine befasst hätte,
ging's halt so hoch und dann war so, ja okay, die Krimis irgendwie weg und dann war das wieder weg und andere Themen. Ah ich glaube.
Bis das jetzt so wirklich hochging, zumindest in meinem Umfeld, war das auch für niemand ein Thema. Also ja, kennt man irgendwie und dann gibt's hier eine Krise und da und die Ukraine, aber ähm
So wenn man die Leute fragt, was in Frankreich los, konnten die einem zehn mal so viel erzählen wie zu Ukraine und die Distanz vom Berlin ist so halbwegs die gleiche irgendwie zu den Ländern. Also aber halt wie du sagst dieses Ost und West äh,
die Menschen aus dem Westen, für die es Paris, glaube ich, deutlich näher als so vom Gefühl her, weil in dem einen können sie dir sagen, da steht der Eiffelturm und da gibt's Baguettes und bei Leve sagen wir keine Ahnung, da drüben irgendwie.
Genau, das ist auch immer so ein bisschen das Problem, dass einfach auch diese ganzen,
osteuropäischen, politischen Zusammenhänge immer auch irgendwie mit so mhm,
schwierig zu durchschauen sind, ne? Dann gab's dann auf einmal so diese Wiesegrad
die sich da so aufgestellt haben gegenüber dem Westen so nach dem Motto ah nee, wir wollen nicht hier irgendwie alles so machen, wie ihr das macht, weil wir haben irgendwie auch eine andere Sicht der Dinge auf Freiheit, äh auf äh.
Und was nicht alles so nicht war, dann halt irgendwie dieser Kampf der EU,
gegenüber Polen und Ungarn, die so eine Achse gebildet haben, die jetzt definitiv, glaube ich, äh grade äh leidet. Ähm.
Und die Ukraine war halt dann wieder so ein das war dann noch weiter weg und noch noch mal ein bisschen komplizierter, obwohl ich so den Eindruck habe, dass jetzt alle gerade so denken so, hätten wir mal lieber genauer,
hingeschaut, nicht? Weil da sind schon die ganzen Ereignisse so mit mit Trump und Selenski und äh was da alles so gelaufen ist, äh in den letzten Jahren. Es hätte genug Anlass gegeben. Andererseits muss man natürlich sagen,
Es gibt noch,
Hunderte andere solcher äh Konstellationen und politischen Krisen Orte auf diesem Planeten, die man sich im Prinzip mal genauer anschauen sollte und wo man vielleicht mal besser verstehen sollte, was ist, was da für ein Potential drinsteckt. Aber es ist natürlich jetzt äh,
Seit dem Krieg ist es natürlich anders jetzt äh berichtet sogar UKW darüber.
Ja also es gibt zu viele Krisen auf der Welt und ich denke immer
beschäftige mich zwangsläufig mit einigen von denen, also ist meine also ich bekomme ja schon mehr von diesen Dingen mit als vielleicht so der Durchschnittsmensch
Ich merke auch immer wieder, wenn ich dann mit Kollegen spreche, deren Fokus auf irgendwas anderem ist, sagen die, hast du das in Türgisier nicht mitbekommen? Sage ich, nee, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß grob, wo's liegt. Ah ich könnt's jetzt blind aufm Atlas auch nicht genau sagen.
Vielleicht doch kühl ist da ein heiß.
Ja genau, dann geht's nicht los mit diesen nein, nein, es ist, da gibt's dann die zwei Fraktionen, was ist es, ne,
Ja und genau und das meine ich halt, das ist ähm ja, da verstehe ich auch, dass ein normaler Mensch sagt, oh geil, gibt Bier. Äh keine Ahnung, was da drüben los ist.
So, jetzt bist du gerade zurückgekommen aus der Ukraine. Du warst dort für eine Woche.
Das hat bei dir ja so Plan, ich ticke ja immer so, ah irgendwann komme ich mal mit und so und dann äh ja aber dann lese ich, dann mache ich irgendwie Twitter auf und dann so ja bin gerade wieder im Anflug auf.
Land, wo Dinge passieren,
Ähm also warst du schon wieder unterwegs wie kurzfristig entscheidest du solche Sachen eigentlich?
Also in dem Fall war's so, also ich meine, ich habe die ganze Zeit gesagt, hm, sollte man, sollte man nicht hin und her und also so.
Ähm und der äh entscheidende Punkt war wieder fideles mit dem ich halt da schon in Kramatos war. Der rief mich an und sagte hey ich muss irgendwie nach Kiew, willste mit?
Wann, wie, was genau? Sagt der, äh ich bin grad in Berlin angekommen. Wie lange brauchst du ein Packen?
Geht schnell, also in in dieser Branche hat man so Weste Helm und Gasmaske eh mal in einer extra Tasche liegen. Ähm.
Also mit Branche mal zu Journalist.
Ja genau, also so Journalismus im im im gefährlichen Bereich. Also ist echt so die Reisetasche mit dem Kram und.
Äh dann gesagt, okay, lass uns morgen früh losfahren und dann schauen wir mal. Also es war so von, ich weiß nicht, acht Stunden Vorlauf oder so,
In die Tasche werfen, also noch so dann auch für wie lange packe ich? Keine Ahnung. Gibt's da eine Waschmaschine? Das mag Trivialklingas. Kommt drauf an, ob's Wasser und Strom gibt,
Ähm also so gesagt, ah für eine Woche die Sachen einpacken. Dann auch so Dinge, die,
die manchmal rückblickend völlig bescheuert wirken. Wir haben überlegt, gibt's da zu essen und wo? Also weil das kann sich von Ort zu Ort unterscheiden,
zur Sicherheit habe ich so wie so Energiekekse eingepackt, also so so Notfallessen oder wie man's nennen würde,
Nicht, dass ich dachte, wir verhungern da, aber wenn man zum Beispiel aufm Weg raus, weil wieder doch irgendwas Schlimmes passiert, dann kann's sein, dass man ein, zwei Tage an so einer Grenze festhängt oder als die Leute aus Kabul evakuiert wurden, haben zum Teil zwei Tage aufm Flughafen gesessen,
Da ist nicht klar, wie oder was es an Essen gibt. Und wenn du dann da irgendwie deine Packung Energiekekse hast, äh dann hast du zumindest Kalorien und Vitamine. Ähm also auch so Kram.
Ist das so ein Military Food.
So in der Art, also es war eher so, die gibt so einen Prepper-Store, wo man sich damit komischen Leuten in der Schlange äh wiederfindet. Aber sagen wir mal.
Mit den Querdenkern, ja.
Die sind durch, aber sie haben von ihrem Fachgebiet Ahnung wie niemand. Das ist immer sehr strange, auch wenn man so guckt, welche Gasmaske ist für welche Zwecke gut. Man landet bei den wirsten Leuten, die einem sagen, was hilft, wenn welche Echsenmenschen angreifen,
Sie können dir exakt sagen, welcher Filter für welche Giftgase zuständig.
Äh
Ah ja und aber so rückwirkend war's so, es gab halt natürlich überall hatten die Cafés und Bistros auf und äh an der Grenze ging schnell, aber wann sagt weißt du vorher nicht. Ähm.
Das heißt, den ganzen Scheiß zusammenschmeißen und wir haben auch tatsächlich Gasmasken mit Sarinschutzfiltern und so was mitgenommen, falls es doch,
Gas oder irgendwas gibt. Dann haben wir gesagt, das äh vielleicht nicht, vielleicht schon, aber sagen wir so,
Es wäre ziemlich blöde, wenn nachher da steht, Enno ist leider an Giftgas gestorben und er hatte eine Gasmaske, aber die hat er zu Hause gelassen. Also so man sagt also so der Spruch ist halt time.
Ist nicht so schwer, aber das wäre echt sozusagen mit dem großen Gepäck äh losgefahren sind mit allem, was man brauchte und vor allem medizinisches Equipment. Also wenn man irgendwo hinfährt, was heißt, ja da ist so ein bisschen eine Krise okay,
Wenn wir davon reden, dass wir durch ein aktives Kriegsgebiet mit Autos fahren, da kann's halt sein, dass man beschossen wird und.
Oder auf eine Mine fährt.
Genau und da musst du sofort den Blutverlust stoppen, der Rest ist fast egal. Aber du hast halt,
eine Minute ungefähr, in der du dich selber versorgen kannst, bist du äh bist du ohnmächtig wirst in zwei Minuten ungefähr bist du tot bist. Das heißt da geht's um Geschwindigkeit,
heißt alles zum äh Blutungen abbinden und.
Wir hatten echt das ganze Auto voll. Wir hatten also wir haben so ein Foto gemacht, wo wir an den Westen das ganze medizinische Equipment haben, rechts und links in den Taschen im Handschuhfach und hinten noch eine offene Tasche auf der Rückbank.
Als wir in so 'n Checkpoint kamen, haben die auch geguckt und gesagt, OK, ihr habt vielleicht übertrieben, aber vielleicht haben wir auch zu wenig, wir sind uns grade nicht sicher, also man sagt, ja,
Ach so in,
Wenn man wirklich Sorge hat, dass man beschossen wird, dann sollte man sehr vorsichtig sein und alles griffbereit haben und das war halt so, wo wir gesagt haben, okay, alles alles mitnehmen, alles einpacken, alles griffbereit haben,
Und wenn man's am Ende nicht brauchen, OK, sei's drum. Und dann aber sozusagen um den Bogen zur Frage zurückzubringen, ja so einen Tag Vorlauf,
jetzt mehrmals in letzter Zeit für so eine Reise. Ähm viel mehr ist es oft nicht.
Okay? Kurzentschlossen. Äh ich habe ja auch mal so einen Podcast-Koffer hier to go. Wenn ich den äh greife, weiß ich, bin ich für alles äh zu haben, aber ist halt jetzt noch keine schusssichere Weste und Helme und so weiter. Ähm ja, ich weiß.
Bescheid, ne. Ich habe.
Okay, alles klar. Ähm seid ihr da auch mit so einem äh gepanzerten Wagen unterwegs gewesen?
Nee. Ähm also wir hatten gepanzerte Wagen, die äh vor Ort waren,
Gab aber mehrere Sachen zum einen, da wo wir lang gefahren sind, haben wir gesagt ähm wahrscheinlich passiert da nicht viel, ne, berühmte letzte Worte,
Der andere Punkt war, ähm gepanzerte Fahrzeuge haben Unmengen Nachteile, die man nicht vergessen darf. Zum einen, so ein gepanzerter Land Cruiser wiegt ungefähr sechs Tonnen.
Sechs Tonnen.
Okay, das heißt, er schlug dann Sprit wie äh nix Gutes und davon gibt's nicht so viel, ne?
Genau das. Dann, wenn der sich festfährt, war's das,
wenn man durch ein Schlagloch fährt denkt man das Auto explodiert also es ist halt wie mit so einem Laster ein Schlagloch fahren weil halt sechs Tonnen draufdrücken,
der beschleunigt nicht gut, der ist im Handling selbst egal wie gut das Fahrwerk und aller Scheiße ist, es ist halt wie wenn du mit einem kleinen Laster fährst,
und äh und er fällt auf. Also wenn man also wenn ich die Straße lang laufe, kann ich dir sofort sagen, welcher Wagen gepanzert ist und welcher nicht und bei den Land Cruisern auch halbwegs welcher Hersteller, weil wenn man wenn man Blick hat, hat man Blickwirft.
Die anderen wissen, dass man gepanzert fährt, das heißt, man ist interessant. Ähm,
Das heißt, es gibt viele, viele, viele Nachteile und die Vorteile sind gar nicht so viele. Also man sagt ja, man ist gepanzert, hm ja, man ist Physik. Man ist vor bestimmten physikalischen Ereignissen in bestimmten Bereichen geschützt.
Aber ganz vielen nicht. Wenn eine Mine kommt, ist man nicht geschützt. Wenn äh Cruise Missile kommt, ist man nicht geschützt. Wenn man sich festfährt, kriegt man die Karre nicht raus und,
Der Schütze muss ja einen selber treffen, der muss wenn der durch die Scheibe schießt, kann mir das halbwegs egal sein, solange er mein Körper nicht trifft und er muss meinen Körper treffen, da wo ich nicht die schusssichere Weste treffe, das heißt,
Es ist eine unglaubliche Fummelarbeit für ein Scharfschützen, ein fahrendes Fahrzeug, da eine Person drin zu treffen. Ähm.
Und deswegen meine ich, dass es fast immer besser ist, ein unpanzertes Auto zu fahren. Auch ein Problem ist,
schießt er auf die Scheibe, dann hat man so ein 20 Zentimeter Flatschen auf der Scheibe, durch den man nicht mehr gucken kann, weil das halt so Plastikfolien und Glas und so ist es dann halt wie so Sicherheitsglas gesplittert,
schießt auf nur ungepanzerte Scheibe, habe ich so einen sechs bis acht Millimeter Loch drin und kann durch den Rest noch gucken.
So ganz viele Dinge, die man abwägen muss. Und im Prinzip kann man sagen, gepanzert fahren oder schnell fahren und wir sind schnell gefahren. Weil dann kann man nicht gut drauf zielen.
Und spritschonend.
Mittel, wir haben also,
die Strecken sind mäßig, aber wir sind wirklich einen also laut Bordcomputer, einen Schnitt von 140 Gefahren zwischen und Kiev auf der Straße.
Es ist sehr schnell. Also so im Prinzip immer am Anschlag vom Tacho, wenn's irgendwie möglich ist, also überall, wo's gefährlich ist. Ähm und das ist,
auch anstrengend, also das muss man also wir üben so was in verschiedenen Trainings, aber so ein also,
so ein PKW quasi auf 200 fahren,
für drei, vier Stunden, das ist sehr anstrengend, gerade wenn man dann sich umgucken muss und die Straße nicht kennt. Also da ist auch gut, wenn man mit zwei Leuten fährt, die das gewohnt sind im Team, also echt wie so ein Relly-Team. Einer guckt, einer fährt.
Und für die Situation meine ich immer noch, dass das wesentlich besser ist, weil der gepanzerte Wagen zieht einfach mehr Aufmerksamkeit.
Mhm. Seid ihr jetzt schnell gefahren, weil ihr schnell da sein wolltet oder weil man schnell weniger Ziel ist.
Beides. Also man kann sagen, zum einen, wir wollten schnell da sein, weil na, man fährt ja, um anzukommen, also Sightseeing-Tour ist es dann auch nicht da,
deswegen immer wenn man fährt schnell und wenn man steht möglichst unter einer Brücke oder irgendwas was Schutz bietet ähm und dann schnell raus und wieder rein.
Aber sozusagen, wenn man sich bewegt, dann so schnell wie möglich hm weil dann ist man auch wieder schnell aus dem Bereich raus, in dem jemand überhaupt schießen könnte.
Von Levis nach Kiew sind's auch knapp sechshundert Kilometer, also.
Sind so sechshundert, dann ungefähr, ja.
Also würde man von Berlin ins Ruhrgebiet fahren, so die Größenordnung. Ähm ist schon was so vor vor allem durch Kriegsgebiet, wo immer mal so Zeug rumliegt.
Also wir hatten äh ja wir hatten alles. Also der sag mal so die erste Hälfte der Strecke,
das nennt sich der Highway E vierzig, aber Highway oder also Autobahn ist ein bisschen übertrieben. Das ist stellenweise eine Landstraße mit einer Spur pro Richtung und teilweise so Autobahn mit zwei Spuren pro Richtung.
Aber so Autobahnen mit Zebrastreifen. Das kannte ich auch nicht. Da kommt dann so, Achtung, Fußgängerüberweg. Und also so Sachen, an die man sich gewöhnen muss. War niemand unterwegs, es war auch unglaublich leer.
Aber so ab der Hälfte also ungefähr so so ganz grob in der Mitte zwischen und Kiew,
war's so, dass uns also wir haben eine genaue Anleitung bekommen, wie wie wir nach Kiew fahren.
Das hieß, ihr müsst von Süden nach Kier fahren, weil westlich von Kiew ist Russisch noch irgendwie kontrolliert oder unklar oder da wird noch ab und zu geschossen,
Ist auch so ein Problem vor Ort. Wir haben versucht rauszufinden, ist jetzt die ganze Autobahn unter ukrainischer Kontrolle oder nicht?
So trivial diese Frage ist, wir konnten's vor Ort nicht rausfinden. Keiner konnte es uns sicher sagen. Dann hieß es ja, ja klar, seit gestern ist das kein Problem und dann sagt jemand, nee, aber heute sind da Leute beschossen worden ja hm,
und dann war's so, dass wir ab dem Ort ich weiß nicht, ob ihn ihn richtig ausgesprochen hat, da sollten wir nach Süden abbiegen und dann über so verschiedene Dörfer und so fahren,
und ähm das Sicherheitsteam, mit dem wir arbeiten, hat uns wirklich so eine seitenlange Anweisung gegeben, fahrt über die Straße zu dem Ort, über die Straße, zu dem Ort und so weiter und so weiter.
Als wir dann aber in dieser sozusagen an dieser Stelle, an dieser Abfahrt standen,
Haben wir dann die äh die ukrainischen Soldaten da gefragt und haben gesagt, hey, wir wollen nach Kiew.
Geradeaus wäre der schnellste Weg, aber das heißt, das geht nicht und hier zur Seite ist der sichere Weg. Was sagt ihr? Also wie, ne?
Sagt die haben gerade Jahre, so Mittel, warte mal einen Moment. Ich frage mal sozusagen den Kollegen ein Stück weiter und den Kollegen ein Stück weiter.
Sagten wir ja, das geht, also mhm haben gesagt, okay, also erst mal eine Sache,
müssten paar Minuten warten, weil da vorne müssen wir noch was sprengen, also eine Granate oder Munition oder also so nicht riesig, nicht eine Riesenbombe, es hat einen fetten Knall gegeben und so eine leichte Druckwelle,
irgendwie wer vermute mal so vom Panzer so eine so ein Stück Munition oder so gefunden haben, wo sie gesagt haben einfach spreng, dann ist es entschärft. Dann kann nichts mehr passieren, ne.
Sagt, seid vorsichtig, also ihr seid so mit die ersten, also sagen, ihr seid die ersten nicht Einheimischen, die jetzt hier rüberfahren. Also passt auf.
Äh nichts anfassen, gar nichts, nicht eine Leiche, nicht ein Auto, weil da können Sprengfallen oder so ein Scheiß drin sein,
Auch denke am Ende gab's da bisher wohl nirgends welche, das weiß man halt vorher nicht. Also schön, schön vorsichtig sein,
Beispiel zum Vergleich, wir haben in Afghanistan ein Auto mal aufgemacht und da war eine Mine drin, die mit der Tür auf der anderen Seite verdrahtet war.
Nicht die Tür, die wir aufgemacht haben, Glück gehabt und so kam passiert halt. Also so dass man sagt, das ist nicht Blödsinn, das kann passieren.
Und die haben halt gesagt also vorsichtig sein, nichts anfassen, wenn irgendwas komisch ist, wendet euch an uns oder an die nächsten Kollegen und ne, so passt auf euch auf.
Und dann sind wir also halt hm war so ein bisschen hin und her immer schnell gefahren.
Zwischen da wo's ging und da wo man dann irgendwas äh sehen oder angucken konnte, geguckt, wo kann man irgendwie halbwegs in Deckung stehen und da waren zum Beispiel abgeschossene Panzer, die da rumstanden.
Oder so, also verschiedene Kettenfahrzeuge mit Rohr, ohne Rohr, also große militärische gepanzerte Fahrzeug.
Ganzen Fotos, die man jetzt einfach.
Also so.
Durchgereicht bekommt auf Twitter.
Alles, was der Laie so als Panzer, sagen wir mal, identifiziert.
Und dann stoppt man halt dahinter, weil der bietet ja immer noch ein bisschen Schutz und dann wieder weiterfahren, wieder stehenbleiben und hin und her.
Und ähm dann kam's, also fing's an, dass da äh so zivile Autos standen, also so äh alte Laders oder VW Busse oder so kamen, die aber völlig zerschossen waren, also wirklich wie,
vorstellt, wenn so Amis äh auf einer Shooting-Ranch irgendwie so ein Auto stehen haben, was sie zum Spaß zerschießen, also der löchert von vorne bis hinten und,
auch gesagt, das ist halt sehr merkwürdig, wenn du sozusagen als einer, der erst da langfährst und dann sagst, okay, dann stehen da einfach so diese also Autos, die aussehen wie deins oder das von Freunden oder so nicht ein Panzer, nicht irgendwas Militärisches, sondern,
Ein normales Auto, also somit Bommeln am Spiegel und irgendwie keine Ahnung, irgendeinem Aufkleber drauf,
und 1 der ersten, zu dem wir dann gegangen sind lass mal gucken, weil was was ist hier los? Also so wie wie ist die Lage.
Und ähm dann sagte fidele schon, ey, pass auf, da liegt jemand hinter. Also so da hier liegen noch Körper.
Und war halt wirklich so, dass sah halt aus, als sei derjenige ausgestiegen und in Deckung gegangen, also so wie in der Zeit stehen geblieben, wie in so einem Horrorfilm oder so, wenn man so äh also so,
aber er sagte am ehesten wie bei twenty eight theys later so die die Welt wurde quasi verlassen von den meisten Menschen oder sie wurden zu Zombies und dann stehen so Sachen rum die einfach wie wie wenn man in der Zeit auf Stopp gedrückt hat.
Der Wagen äh also stand da halt, die Tür war auf und er war so zusammengekauert hinterm Reifen und war halt tot.
Und ähm und war aber noch da. Also so war noch niemand da war zum Aufräumen. Waren dann halt auch sagt so okay ähm.
Fängt man jetzt mit der Situation an
Also so äh wer war das? Was was passiert? Dann sagte er war ziemlich sicher Zivilist, außer der hat sich noch ganz schnell bevor erschossen wurde, umgezogen auf zivile Kleidung und hat noch schnell einen Bommel in sein Auto gehangen, ne? Man sagt, nee, das war ganz sicher kein Soldat.
Und ähm ja kann man halt nichts machen. Also dann fährt man halt weiter, weil irgendwann wird schon Aufräumtrupp kommen, der sich drum kümmert und was was soll man tun. Dann auch so Sachen Tankstellen, die aufgebrochen waren, also waren da die Schiebetüren waren so eingeschlagen,
und dann lagen aber davor Leichen und man sah halt drinnen,
so irgendwie noch Füße und eine Hose liegen, wo also wir sind auch in so Gebäude nicht reingegangen, weil man nicht weiß, wie sicher da unsicher das ist. Ähm.
Aber halt so und das halt nicht so an ein, zwei Stellen, sondern es zog sich sogar,
irgendwas zwischen 50 und 100 Kilometern oder auch dass wir auf der Straße fuhren, dann immer gesagt haben, warte, da liegt was, jetzt ganz vorsichtig drum rumfahren und dann ist das ein Körper oder nicht oder dass man sagt, hm, es ist nicht ein ganzer Körper, der da liegt,
Also echt übelste Sachen und das also wie so ein Trümmerfeld, was ich einfach von vorne bis hinten da lang zog.
Und ab und zu kamen dann Autos vorbei, entweder von anderen Zivilisten, die wahrscheinlich auf dem Weg zurück in ihre Heimat oder so waren?
Oder von so Soldaten oder diesen freiwilligen ähm Soldaten oder wie sich das genau nennt, die haben auch zum Teil angehalten und gesagt, ey alles okay, also so
Habt ihr euch verfahren? Wollt ihr hier langfahren? Ist alles okay. Ähm braucht ihr Hilfe? Sagt nee nee alles gut wir sind Journalisten, also wir hatten auch Presseschildern, Helm, Weste an am Auto und so
War dann auch immer kein Problem äh aber es war halt schon ja also,
So am laufenden Band so Dinge, also von von vorne bis hinten, das ist schon also sehr übel anzusehen.
Die Strecke, die du jetzt beschrieben hast, von nach Kiew, das sind so hundert120 Kilometer ungefähr äh redest du jetzt von diesem Zustand über die ganze Strecke quasi ab dem Ort oder.
In Etappen, also so dann war auch mal zehn Minuten nix. So wenn man gefahren ist und dann stand wieder so ein Panzer und dann lag also so so mal war's, dann war nix, dann war ein bisschen mehr, also es ging so hin und her kann man sagen, aber so,
Im Prinzip ja, war die ganze Strecke verteilt. Also so äh in in Etappen. Also oder in so Clustern, ja.
Die Straße führt ja dann unter anderem vorbei an äh
knapp an äh irpin, das sind ja so zwei Orte, die man so in den letzten Wochen häufiger gehört hat, weil da ging's richtig ab, da standen die Russen, da hatten sie ihre ganzen Artillerie aufgebaut und haben von dort aus,
beschossen und natürlich auch der Ort diverser äh Auseinandersetzungen gewesen und äh dann.
Direkt neben äh ist äh Buccar, was jetzt noch mal in die Nachrichten kam, weil's dort.
Also entweder besonders schlimm war oder es zumindest der erste Ort war, den man jetzt so gefunden hat, wo es besonders äh schlimm war, also während Irpin im Wesentlichen so ein bisschen die Grenze war,
der Auseinandersetzung äh war Butcha halt die ganze Zeit quasi russisch besetzt und ihr seid dann.
Von der Straße ab direkt nach Butcha gefahren oder wie?
Also wir waren in Mühler, das oder Mila, das ist so der Ort auf der Autobahn, von dem's dann nach Butscher ab.
Am Samstag also am letzten Samstag und da ich glaube das war die Uhrzeit zu der noch niemand kannte das Dorf und am Abend kannte es jeder. Also wir waren genau in der Zwischenzeit da.
Und äh da waren wir also so Richtung Butscher und haben auch die die Ortsschilder und alles gesehen, aber es hat halt noch keine Relevanz dieser Name. Also was auch so komisch ist, dass man quasi daneben stand in dem Moment und eine Stunde oder zwei später,
die ganze Welt den Namen, aber da lagen auch schon überall, also die die Leute rum oder zum Teil, sie saßen halt noch in den Autos, also es war halt noch nichts, noch nichts aufgeräumt,
und.
Äh da wo diese riesen Gefechte waren, also es war auch zum Teil so, dass wir auf der Autobahn gefahren sind und dann war so eine Serie von Löchern, also das ist ein riesiges MG einmal quer über die Autobahn geschossen haben muss, also dass man,
so faustgroße Löcher, zwei Reihen komplett von rechts nach links über alle vier Spuren hatte,
auch denkt, okay das das muss groß gewesen sein,
oder auch, dass da offensichtlich Panzerquerer die Autobahn gefahren sind und die Mittelleitplanke und die Schallschutzwände rechts und links platt gefahren haben.
Also ich habe eine Menge Unfälle im Leben gesehen und die Autos sind meistens in der Leitplanke hängengeblieben, also die Dinger sind stabil. Man dann sieht, wie das einfach so umgeknickt ist, wo man auch denkt, was für eine,
Kraft. Da wirkt also sozusagen im zivilen Leben, ist eine Leitplanke unglaublich stark,
Kommt zum Panzer und rollt drüber oder halt, dass wirklich das Würste, wo wir echt da gestanden haben und gesagt haben, sind wir jetzt zu blöd, da lag eine Panzerkette und die sind so einen halben Meter breit und zehn Meter oder so lang, wenn die ausgerollt ist,
Stück weiter lag der Turm vom Panzer das runde Ding mit dem Kanonenrohr wo ist der Panzer?
Er sagt, das ist so jedes dieser Teile wie Tonnen, wo ist der Panzer? Und sind hin und her gelaufen und haben gesagt, wir haben ihn nicht gesehen. Es hat was.
Wo soll der denn sein? Der fliegt doch nicht weg. Wahrscheinlich war er die Böschung runter, da irgendwas, aber dass da so ein Turm vom Panzer liegt und an dem Panzer nicht findet. Das äh,
unglaublich.
Ist ja eine Eigenschaft dieser russischen.
T zweiundsiebzig, ja.
T zweiundsiebzig, dass die quasi durch dieses automatische
Nachladesystem für das Kanonenrohr quasi so ein Kranz von geschossen haben und wenn man halt wirklich mit so einem oder was auch immer von oben äh trifft, ist ja die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass allein schon durch den Druck sich dort äh alles äh entzündet, sehr hoch und
so viele fliegende Panzertürmer und äh vielleicht ist es einfach mit Kette so weit geflogen, dass der Panzer schon nicht mehr in der Nähe war.
Steht und also während das wirklich live sieht, sagt man wie, also was sind das denn für.
Kann das sein? Ja hm.
So das ist also so Dinge werden da wirklich vorsteht sich da einfach denkt, was was zur Hölle ist hier passiert? Also so ja klar, der Turm ist weggeflogen, aber wie, was? Also,
Das ist schon äh ja also so also man man kann es kaum erfassen oder begreifen was los ist.
Das heißt, du warst dann in Buscha quasi noch bevor du überhaupt in Kiel fährst.
Genau, also wir waren da auf dieser sozusagen auf der Straße, die also von der E vierzig rübergeht,
Dann sind wir aber auch relativ bald nach Kiew weiter, weil eigentlich wollten wir ja nach Kiew, also eigentlich war ja unser Ziel nach Kiew fahren und dann gucken, wie's weitergeht.
Sozusagen das, weil wir in dem Moment da waren, wo die Soldaten entschieden haben, dass man vorsichtig wieder Body-Auto-Fahrbahn fahren kann, sind wir sozusagen durch ein totalen Zufall,
da als so mit die ersten oder als welche von den Ersten überhaupt lang gefahren. Und so ungefähr ab diesem Ort Mila oder Müller ähm,
Da stand dann auch auf einmal andere Journalisten, also das ist auch so bizarr, Journalisten treten ja oft im Rudel auf in so Gegenden.
Also weil man redet viel miteinander, es ist eine so Kriegsberichterstatters an sich eine sehr sehr enge Szene, zumindest die, die wirklich ganz vorne sind, da wo es knallt, egal welcher Sender, egal wo, egal wie.
Kennen sich alle.
Kennen sich alle, achten auch alle aufeinander und helfen alle. Also das ist auch ähm sehr, sehr spannend, wie das immer noch klappt,
stehen da halt Leute rum mit so einem zwei Meter Selfie-Stick von einem kaputten Panzer und reden, also so wie wie man's halt irgendwie vorm Brandenburger Tor sieht, wenn da die Touris sind. Es ist halt so ein obskuures Bild. Man denkt oder auch,
Leute da hin und her laufen so zu zweit um eine Leiche und von allen Seiten gucken und Fotos machen und denkt.
Das sieht erstmal echt ähm piatlos aus,
aber auf der anderen Seite, die müssen das eine Foto schießen, mit dem die ganze Welt versteht, was passiert ist. Und die wollen ja nicht die,
die Leiche sozusagen im Detail, sondern du sollst erahnen, da es die Leiche, da ist der Panzer und da ist das Wohnhaus oder so und dann ist das Wohnhaus oder der Panzer gut zu sehen und dass man sich gleich so grob denken kann, wo ich denke, ja,
Wenn man das so von außen sieht, wie die Arbeit ist, dann denkt man sich immer, dass sie also es sieht völlig bizarr aus, als würde das da nicht hingehören,
haben wir gesagt, okay hier kommen jetzt also schon die Journalisten aus Kiew hin. Also wir sind sozusagen dicht genug an Kiew, dass das, wo die sich so immer weiter raus getraut haben, dass sich jetzt die beiden Welten treffen, also von wie weit man von Levis kann,
von Kiew kann, das ist jetzt verbunden. Also das ist wieder eine Welt sozusagen über diese Autobahn.
Und die haben uns dann halt gefragt, was habt ihr da gesehen? Da haben wir gesagt, na das Gleiche wie hier, was habt ihr in eure Richtung gesehen? Sagen die das Gleiche wie hier? Haben gesagt, der war da oben im Norden, äh sagt das Gleiche wie hier und der, der aus dem Süden kommt, das Gleiche, also äh überall.
Überall Zerstörung, überall Leichen.
Auch so Kriegsverbrechen, klar, sind ja russische Armee, natürlich gibt's Kriegsverbrechen, also auch für die Leute, für die Journalisten überhaupt keine Überraschung da,
Und ich glaube, warum Butcha so das Riesensymbol wurde? Also sagen wir mal, der Zivilist, den wir da neben dem zerschossenen Auto hatten,
könnte man ja sagen, na vielleicht war's aber ein Soldat und der hat das Auto benutzt, um zum Einsatz zu fahren und er hatte gerade sich umgezogen oder irgendeinen Scheiß.
Oder sagen wir mal, wenn man wirklich ein sehr sehr kritischer Journalist ist und sagt, ich glaube das gerne privat, aber ich muss sicher sagen können, ist das Kriegsverbrechen oder nicht,
Kann man bei allem sagen, aber aber. Also wenn man so ähm äh den Anwalt des Teufels spielt,
Wenn man dann aber einen Butscherleute hat, Zivilisten mit ähm Händen auf den Rücken gefesselt und ein Loch hinten im Kopf.
Man sagen okay, der Soldat hat sich also zivil umgezogen, sich selber Handschellen angelegt und sich dann hinten in den Kopf geschossen. Nee, die Story glaube ich nicht mehr. Also dass man sagen kann, das ist der Punkt definitiv, jetzt haben wir den Beweis.
Ich glaube deswegen ist das so hoch gekommen und alle sagen klar, rechts, links, vorne, hinten, also überall ist das.
Aber hier hast du einen Ortsnamen, den die Leute googeln können, den sie finden und die Fotos, die absolut hundert Prozent klar das aussagen, wo niemand mehr irgendwas relativieren kann.
Glaube, das ist dann immer so der eine Ort, also wie zum Beispiel Srebrenica. Es gab auch genug Massaker rechts und links von Srebrenica. Aber das war, wo's die Aufnahmen gibt, wo's ganz klar war, wo die UN weggeguckt hat und so weiter.
Wenn so alles zusammenkommt, dann sind das immer der eine Ort, auf den sich's fokussiert. Ich denke, das verstehe ich ja auch total,
Weil dann kann man auch, wenn man, wenn man in New York am Schreibtisch sitzt und keinen vor Ort hat, sagt man, das ist das Bild, wo ich jetzt sehe,
guten Gewissen schreiben, wir haben Kriegverbrechen gesehen,
Und ich glaube, das ist halt ähm das ist halt ja quasi das ist dann der Ort, wo sich alle drauf stürzen. Und zum einen denke ich, ist es gut, dass das so um die Welt geht, dass alle sagen, okay, jetzt glauben wir's.
Auf der anderen Seite traurig, weil's halt wie gesagt 100 Kilometer in jede andere Richtung da irgendwie genauso aussieht.
Und äh die Frage in den letzten Tagen war auch immer wieder bei Leuten und das war ein Butcher. Und die Journalisten sagen, ist doch scheißegal, wo sie dem Zivilisten ins Genick geschossen haben.
Die Aufmerksamkeit ist aber ja in dem Ort, den ich gesehen habe. Also es ist so ein bisschen ambivalent immer mit diesem ein berühmten Ort sozusagen.
Aber so so erkläre ich's mir.
Dann seid ihr.
Nach Kiew rein.
Nach Kiev rein, dann wieder zurück zur Autobahn und äh quasi den Weg fortgesetzt, den ihr äh haben wolltet. Hätte ja theoretisch noch eine andere Verbindung gegeben, aber das war wahrscheinlich dann so äh umkämpftes Gebiet, dass man da auch nichts das war wahrscheinlich noch nicht freigeräumt, ne.
Im Kern immer auf der großen Straße bleiben im Großen. Also so im Prinzip die großen Straßen sind meistens die sicheren, weil sie halt zuerst gesichert werden,
Wie gesagt, wir hatten überhaupt keine Idee, dass Butscha so relevant ist. Also so das ist halt ne, du bist die ganze Seite an Ortsschildern vorbeigefahren,
Und nachher heißt ey, das eine war echt wichtig. Also es ist so komisch in dem Moment, ja.
Also zu dem Zeitpunkt wusstet ihr das sozusagen noch nicht, dass das so hochkochen würdet, aber ihr wart da.
Wie sah das dann aus, wenn man sich wirklich dem Käferstadtzentrum genähert hat? Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass man da so eine gesicherte Stellung nach der anderen sieht.
Unglaublich, also da also,
Wie wenn man als Kind so eine Burg gebaut hat und noch einen Ring drum und noch eine und noch eine und noch eine und noch eine und noch eine. Weil wir kamen halt durch so ähm diese Checkpoints, die sind da im Großen und Ganzen mit
Betonblöcken ähm großen Stahlträgern und Sandsäcken gesichert und so verschiedene Konstruktionen dadraus,
spannend, weil wir haben uns ein paar angeguckt und haben gesagt, wie haben die das genau gebaut? Also wovor soll es wie schützen?
Und ähm dann kamen auch Soldaten zum Teil an und haben gesagt, was macht ihr hier? Habe ich gesagt, ey mich interessiert, wie ihr das genau gebaut habt.
Okay, aber keine Fotos und ja nichts posten, weil nicht dass also wir wissen noch nicht, ob noch ein Angriff kommt. Wir wollen nicht, dass irgendjemand eine Idee hat, welches Ding genau wie gebaut ist und sagt, ja logisch,
dann auch mit denen gesprochen, gesagt, hey, ich kenne das in anderen Ländern, in anderen Gegenden, wie das da gebaut ist und grob gesagt, die haben mit den gegebenen Mitteln unglaublich stabile Sachen gebaut. Also wir waren echt,
sehr überrascht, was die da alles rangeschafft hatten, äh zum Teil irgendwie sieht man so ein paar Sandsäcke und sagt und die halten und sagen die ja, guck mal, dahinter ist ein Bagger.
Und die ähm der ist innen quasi wir haben ein ein Loch ausgehoben mit Beton gefüllt, den Bagger reingestellt,
und davor die Sandsäcke gestapelt. Wenn da jetzt einer vorfährt, bleibt er voll im Bagger hängen, der im Betonfuß hängt,
Aber er denkt, es sind Passantsäcke. Sagt geschickt. Okay, also so und so in der Art gab's hunderte Sachen. In der Art, wo man sagt,
Ah, da hat jemand so drei Schritte weitergedacht. Ich hätte einfach Sandsäcke gestapelt. Und dann kam aber.
Also auch das ist dann nicht so ein Stapel Sandsäcke, sondern so eine Barrikade ist dann fünf Meter lang oder so und besteht aus verschiedenen Schichten und ist drei Meter hoch oder so.
Fährt man hundert Metern, da kommt die nächste und dann fährt man hundert Meter, es kommt die nächste. Da haben wir gesagt, wie viel habt ihr denn gebaut von den Sachen und es kam noch eins und noch eins und noch eins und es hörte überhaupt nicht mehr auf. Also es waren, ich weiß nicht,
zehn, 20 so Verteidigungsringe oder so. Hm und auch zum Teilen so was wie so Hochhausschluchten,
man sich auch denkt, okay und hinter jedem Fenster könnte dann einer mit einer anti äh Panzerwaffe sitzen oder ein Scharfschütze mit einem Riesengewehr, oder du weißt nicht was,
Also das äh also zumindest die Zufahrtsstraße, über die wir kamen, wenn da die Panzerkolonne gekommen wäre, das wird einfach nur ein Riesengemetzel gegeben von vorne bis hinten. Also,
da kann man sagen, da werden vielleicht 1 Prozent von den Leuten, also von den russischen Soldaten auf der anderen Seite, wieder rausgekommen. Ähm war, also es war,
Also sozusagen so als Nerd sagt man ja, boah das habt ihr geschickt gebaut, Respekt und wie habt ihr dieses Detail gelöst, also dass man sagt, das ist ja richtig äh.
Also da hat jemand richtig gut nachgedacht und so diese ganzen friemeligen Details echt schick gelöst und auf der anderen Seite halt erschreckend, so wie also wieder Leute so diese Verteidigungswelle gebaut haben, die halt eben nicht,
Also nicht wie die große militärische Anlage, nicht was man so von den Amis denkt, so einen fetten Raketenschild, sondern im Prinzip aus Baustoffen, Unmengen davon, äh weil's halt nix anderes.
Und auch die.
Die Soldaten, die da standen, was lustig war, die hatten oft echt gute Laune. Also die haben so quasi, sie haben grade die die Russen vertrieben und äh war gute Stimmung.
Ein Punkt war auch ähm,
Also als wir dann an den ersten Checkpoint fahren, erfuhren, kam der Soldat an und sagte, das Passwort und wir wussten, dass es Gebiete wohl gibt, wo man ein Passwort, was sich alle sechs Stunden ändert, nennen muss, um durchzukommen. Ne, sagt, hey, sorry, wir wissen's nicht, dann fahren wir woanders lang. Sagt er, nee, das ist das Passwort.
Keine Ahnung.
Was ist das Passwort? Also ich weiß es echt nicht. Sagt na, Slava Ukraini und jetzt fahre weiter. Also so lang lebe die Ukraine und da geht's rein und der hat sich halt nur irgendwie einen blöden Spaß gemacht und wenn das so auffuck,
passieren? Was ist passiert? Irgendwie und dachte, okay, aber wenn das schon wieder klappt, dann,
Irgendwie da muss er gute Laune haben, wenn er sich so einen Spaß erlauben kann. Also so man denkt, okay, das ist ja schon mal positiv zu sehen, dass die zumindest ihren ihren Humor nicht verloren haben, trotz der ganzen üblen Lage. Ähm,
Aber wenn das noch über ist, aber es war echt und die Straßen sonst waren halt leer. Also es war halt so also es waren halt die Soldaten, es waren diese Verteidigungsdinger.
Und sonst war keiner auf der Straße oder fast keiner. Also so im Prinzip echt es waren Leute, die mit dem Hund draußen waren. Das war so das Einzige, was man halt hier und da gesehen hat, also die, die raus mussten,
Es war aber auch so, so als hättest du halt alle Menschen einfach so einen Photoshop so den Filter, nimm mal die Menschen weg, ich will die Straße leer haben und dann aber halt so eine Riesenstadt.
Silent Earths mäßig, ne? Mhm.
Ja ja, genau, genau. Oder so wie diese Lockdown-Aufnahmen aus den verschiedenen Städten, aber man sagt, das also irgendwie ganz merkwürdig.
Ach so, eine Frage noch zu diesen Sicherungen. Man sieht ja immer diese sogenannten Panzersperren, diese komischen Metallkreuze.
Mhm. Diese Tees oder ja? Die klappen.
Helfen die? Wodurch?
Im Prinzip der Panzer verhakt sich drin, also ganz salopp gesagt. Also wenn der rüberfährt, klemmt das so vor der Kette fest und er erfährt so ein Stück hoch und bleibt dann hängen,
Und dann äh hängt der halt also,
Der könnte schon noch so ein bisschen weiter fahren, aber er würde halt auf der einen Seite die ganze Zeit mit dieser Panzersperre überm Boden kratzen. Er kommt nicht mehr richtig voran,
Also so wie wenn du bei einem Fahrrad so ein Brett an den Reifen tack hast, so du kommst schon noch irgendwie voran, aber nicht so richtig. Sie müssen halt stabil genug sein,
bei allen Nichtpanzerwagen ist es halt so, du fährst rauf und dann hebelst du dich selber hoch, also du hebst die Achse hoch und dann steckst du da fest, weil du dich selber aufgebockt hast,
haben wir sogar an einer Stelle gesehen, da hat wahrscheinlich einer nachts die Sperre nicht gesehen oder keine Ahnung
So ein Geländewagen, der hm quasi die Panzersperre unten im Geländewagen stecken hatte und drei Räder in der Luft, wo man auch dachte, boah, ich hoffe, die Leute sind da gut rausgekommen, weil das da jetzt nicht nach dem Angriff aus oder so.
Da muss man auch sagen, was ein bisschen lustig war, damit man halt nicht nachts in diese Sperren knallt, haben sie Reflektoren dran gehabt,
aber weil du ja nicht irgendwie einen Stapel großer Reflektoren hast, hing da zum Teil wie so Signalwesten an einer Ecke und zum Teil einfach Verkehrszeichen, also so Stopp oder Vorfahrt gewähren oder was sie hat, einfach,
Wusste, wenn irgendwas nachts reflektiert, halt mal an, weil wahrscheinlich fährst du gerade auf eine Sperre zu, aber dachte ich da, oh, da haben die aber dran gedacht, dass sie nicht immer einer reinknallt.
Und zum Teil waren's dann aber auch McDonald's Schilder oder so, also irgendwas was reflektierend war, also so ein so ein Wegweiser hier geht's zu McDonald's oder so. Es war zum Teil halt lustig, was da so wie so so was halt das nächste reflektierende Schild war.
In der Ukraine gibt's wenigstens noch McDonald's.
Der Unterschied immer der Gag den Unterschied zwischen der Sowjetunion und Russland in der Sowjetunion gab's Pepsi.
Gibt's kein Pepsi mehr in.
Nee, die sind auch abgezogen.
Ah, okay.
Ja, aber da merkte man so, also auch so,
Sozusagen eine Sperre bauen, aber dann dran denken, dass nachts nicht der Nachbar reinfährt, weil er die nicht sieht. Also noch ein Schild aufschlagen, weil er denkt ja, immer noch ein Stück mitgedacht und noch ein Stück mitgedacht. Na und dann sind wir halt da reingefahren,
gibt ein großes Hotel, in dem quasi alle wichtigen Nachrichtenredaktionen sind. Das gibt's eigentlich immer in so einem Fall. Dann gibt's ähm.
Also zu allererst eigentlich immer CNN, Bild und BBC. Das sind so die ersten drei, die aufschlagen und die auch dauernd aufeinander hängen. Also weil die sich auch untereinander kennen,
Die sind meist in irgendeinem Hotel, was Notstrom mit eigenen Generatoren hat, was eine ordentliche, stabile Internetleitung hat, wie auch immer,
und was einen Pool hat, weil man ausm Pool trinken kann, wenn's kein Wasser mehr gibt. Ganz einfach. Also und dann landet man meistens in irgendeinem Luxushotel,
Das ist sozusagen der Grund, warum die Kriegsberichterstatter dann immer in den kaputten Ländern in einem Luxushotel hängen, weil diese Sachen erfüllt sein müssen. Mein kleines Hotel hat keine eigenen Generatoren.
Und kein Pool.
Der Pool wird dann runter gechlort, dass du ihn trinken kannst, also die verändern echt die Chlor-Mischung, stellen die Poller auf und sagen, hier nicht schwimmen.
Ist jetzt Trinkwasser und dann wird das soweit, der Chlor galt gesenkt, dass du's im Zweifel ohne Abkochen trinken kannst, wenn der Strom nicht mehr geht,
Und das ist so, weil wir oft so Häme bekommen haben, höhe musste natürlich das gute Hotel sein, sagt man ja. Aus genau den Gründen, du brauchst Strom und du brauchst Wasser. Also wenn's belagert wird, ist das entscheidend. Und.
Das war aber so. Zum einen, es sagt immer niemand so richtig offen, welches Hotel das ist. Also sozusagen ach ist wie so ein offenes Geheimnis, aber man propagiert nicht zu sehr, welches das ist,
Im Normalfall kann man das jeweilige Hotel dann auch nicht buchen und die Kollegen hat mir gesagt, welches das ist,
gesagt, ich kann's nicht auf deren Website buchen, wenn ich anrufe, sagen die es ist ausgebucht und so, sagen, ja, ist normal. Das ist immer so, weil man will so die Leute ein bisschen fernhalten.
Wenn man dann reinkommt mit der Presseweste und sagt, ey ich bin jetzt da, ich brauche ein Zimmer, sagen die alles klar, wie viele? Ähm aber es ist halt so, das ist sozusagen das Spiel.
Und in dem Fall ist es noch speziell so, zurzeit gibt's halt diese Lockdowns nachts immer noch in der Ukraine,
variieren ein bisschen, aber im Prinzip 21 bis 6 Uhr ist Ausgangssperre.
Was ich vorhin vergessen habe zu fragen, passiert jetzt vielleicht grad noch du hast ja alles mögliche an Ausrüstung mitgenommen, aber,
dass du auch in die Ukraine überhaupt reinkommst. Das war von vornherein klar oder musste man so was auch vorher noch äh abklären?
Sagen wir mal so abklären immer, aber das ist in dem Fall ganz einfach halt irgendwie auf die Seite von der ukrainischen Botschaft und wenn man nicht rein kann, steht das da irgendwo und dann halt echt ganz trivial Twitter, ukraine Grenze,
suchen und dann sieht man, ey, wir stehen an der Grenze zur Ukraine. Wir haben eine Stunde gebraucht, um reinzukommen. Sagt man, alles klar, Grenze ist offen. Also so trivial kann's sein.
So Visum oder so was äh war jetzt kein Thema.
Mhm auch kein keine Corona-App geprüft oder so, also es war recht liberal.
Und auch dass man Presse ist, erfordert jetzt keine Anmeldung oder so.
Eigentlich meine Erfahrung ist, wenn man Presse ist, ist man herzlich willkommen. Zumindest immer, wenn man, also wenn man nicht auf Seite der Kriegsverbrecher einreist.
Schon klar, aber ich dachte mir, dass man das vielleicht dass man weiß nicht bist du danach gefragt worden äh an der Grenze, haben die das dann notiert? Haben die deine Telefonnummer? Wissen die, dass du quasi da.
Ne, also es ist,
Prinzip, also erstmal so eine normale Grenze halt mit so mehreren Spuren und dann war so Spur gekennzeichnet so Laster, also klar, die sind eh irgendwie abseits, weil die werden besonders gescannt.
Reisebusse, NGO und alle anderen. Und das fand ich relativ cool, weil es gibt diese NGO-Pur, also wenn du mit einem Rettungswagen kommst oder irgendwas, was Hilfeleistung ist, dann kommst du in die Extraspur, dass du schneller durchkommst.
Denkt, das ist schon ganz cool, also dass das so ist,
Da standen auch Soldaten, die haben dann immer auf die Autos gezeigt mit den Roten Kreuzen drauf und gesagt, du da rüber, du darüber fahren die NGO Spur, fahre da rüber.
Also und das waren jetzt nicht nur so was wie offizielle Rettungswagen, sondern so Konvois von fünf Autos, die so rote Kreuze oder so draufgeklebt hatten, so mit Gaffa-Tape und dann ging die hin und sagt, ja, fahr da rüber, ist äh so
Ein Typ im Auto und der Rest voller Hilfsgüter, wir glauben dir, dass du nicht hier irgendwie privat langfährst, fahr darüber. Und wir haben dann so.
Da bei der Einreise auch gar nicht so lange eine Stunde ungefähr gebraucht, bis wir durch waren, also es ging halt immer so Stück für Stück voran und dann hieß es halt okay, was macht ihr hier und wir hatten aber auch auf der Motorhaube und im Fenstern so die Presseschilder, also dass man ordentlich zu erkennen ist.
Es kommt sehr drauf an, ob's Sinn ergibt, sich als Presse kenntlich zu machen oder nicht. Also je nachdem, wie genau und wie gefährlich und.
Aber dort, wo es noch sicher ist, ist es meist gut zu erkennen zu sein, weil die Leute grundsätzlich freundlich sind erstmal und die haben dann auch gesagt, okay ihr seid Journalisten,
Alles klar?
Ähm haben halt ins Auto geguckt und okay irgendwie Kamera, schussige Weste, Helm, bisschen Gepäck, haben gesagt, kannst du einmal die großen Gepäckstücke also in den Koffer aufmachen. Ah okay, einmal Kleidung, vielen Dank und weiter. Also überhaupt gar kein Problem und zack, der nächste Wagen.
Also es geht nur so drum ist der offensichtlich komisch. Also ich glaube, das ist so wirklich nur so die Sichtprüfung. Also wenn ich sage, ich bin irgendwie Presse und dann habe ich zwei Sturmgewehre bei. Dann sagen die, hm das ist aber komisch.
Und äh wenn man da sagt, ich bin Presse und man sieht irgendwie verlottert aus und hat eine schusssichere Weste, dann sagen die, ja, das glaube ich dir. Du siehst aus wie ein Journalist, du kannst rein. Ähm.
Und das war überhaupt kein Problem. Es war halt also Ausreise aus Polen und dann Einreise, also sozusagen,
Polizei, also der Grenzschutz, äh Militär und Zoll. Also man hatte quasi drei Leute, die hintereinander standen,
Und die Polizei sagt nur, hast du ein Pass und Fahrzeugpapiere? Okay, Fahr weiter, das Militär sagt, hm, siehst du aus wie ein russischer Spion? Nee, fahr weiter. Der Zoll sagt, hast du was zu verzollen? Nee, okay, weiter. Also so das sind sozusagen die drei Schritte,
und ähm.
Aber wenn das Zollsystem noch funktioniert, merkt man auch, dass da noch ein noch ein Start am wirtschaften ist.
Genau also und auch alles ganz akkurat, also nicht, dass da nur ein Soldat steht, der so irgendwie Sichtprüfung macht, sondern wirklich alle drei Schritte hintereinander. Also alles noch ganz, ganz regulär, ganz ordentlich und ohne ohne Ausnahmen.
Und äh das war dann halt so in einer Stunde im groben durch. Also auch überraschend schnell, weil wir hatten gedacht, mal sehen, wie lang.
Einen riesen riesen Fehler, den wir in der Planung gemacht haben. Wir haben gar nicht dran gedacht, dass auch in Levis der Lockdown ist, also in Kiew klar, aber Levie ist halt relativ offen noch,
und wir haben dann noch.
Jetzt mit Lockdown, also Ausgangssperren oder was.
Man ab, Ausgangssperre ab 22 Uhr in. Da haben wir gesagt, boah geil, wir haben noch genug Zeit,
Zeitzone, wir müssen eine Stunde vorstellen und ähm wir sind dann 20 Minuten vorm Lockdown im Hotel angekommen. Also es ging noch und die haben gesagt in Levis sind die auch,
geht so. Also wenn du sozusagen von der Grenze reinfährst und sagst, ey ich muss noch zu meinem Hotel, sorry, es hat gedauert. Sagt dann sagen die, ja okay, fallt direkt zu deinem Hotel und.
Ähm sonst musst du halt da stehen bleiben, wo du bist. Dann wartest du, bis du wieder weiter darfst. Sechs Uhr morgens.
Ausgangssperre.
Also im Auto musst du dann da stehen.
Also wir haben nur die Gerüchte gehört von Leuten, die im Auto gepennt haben. Ich habe keinen selber getroffen, aber die sagten, es kommt drauf an, wie hart das am Checkpoint ist. Dann hieß es wohl gut. Dann parkt da, dann sehen wir dich. Ja und dann bleibst du bis sechs Uhr hier.
Hauptsache es bewegt sich nichts.
Genau, also so dass du nicht im Dunkeln hin und her kannst, so dass man sozusagen ein bisschen Augen auf dich hat.
Hm sagt okay, hat ja geklappt, aber hätten wir vielleicht bisschen schlauer drüber nachdenken können.
Und in Kiew war das auch so.
Ein Kiefer sogar ab einundzwanzig Uhr? Warum auch immer eine Stunde früher.
Und da war's also deswegen war's auch gut, dass wir in diesem Hotel mit den ganzen Journalisten waren, weil was machst du einundzwanzig bis sechs Uhr, wenn du mit allen zusammenhängst, dann hast du dann Zeit, über alles zu reden, was am Tag los war und Leute kennenzulernen und alles,
Wenn du dann in irgendeinem Hotel alleine bist, hast du echt Langeweile.
Ja.
Das war da wirklich so. Die Türen waren zu. Also es war abgeschlossen. Es war mit so mit so Stellwänden zu und die war mit Fahrradschlössern aneinander und daneben saß ein Wachmann.
Und das lustige war, er hatte nur ein Foto von einem von einem Journalisten. Wir haben gesagt, warum? Also sozusagen ist das der Böse, auf den du achten musst. Sagt er, nee.
Der darf raus.
Es gab ein, es gibt einen sehr gut vernetzten Journalisten da, der selbst während der Ausgangssperre immer wieder raus durfte und alle waren sehr neidisch auf ihn oder sind's immer noch? Und ähm,
Was auch so ein bisschen lustig ist äh oder so so obskur dann, also,
irgendwie vor 21 Uhr kamen dann alle Leute wieder, dass alle drin sind und in dem Hotel gab's Alkohol von 11 bis 16 Uhr.
Auch gesagt haben, diese Regelung wirft viele Fragen auf. Also das Alkohol limitiert wird okay, aber wer kam drauf, dass man Alkohol von 11 bis 16 Uhr saufen darf?
Aber sonst nicht mehr. Ähm so, aber.
Prohobition immer nur ein Stück weit äh funktioniert, aber es gibt glaube ich generell ein Alkoholverbot, ne?
Ja oder so Einschränkung,
Okay, aber warum ab elf? Aber okay, also so irgendwie also du kannst zum Frühstück dein Bier saufen, aber abends nicht mehr.
War's halt so, dass halt immer um 15 Uhr 59 nochmal 20 Flaschen Bier oder so bestellt wurden ähm und äh halt alle beliebt waren, die von draußen kamen und noch ein paar Flaschen mitgebracht haben.
Im Hotel selber war's dann auch zum Teil so, dann ist man da abends lang gelaufen und es waren ja alle unter sich sozusagen, es waren alle verschiedenen Nachrichtenredaktionen da,
und die zum Teil mieten die dann einfach eine Suite, die sie als Hauptbüromi äh nutzen, also so wo sie dann ihren Besprechungsraum und so haben.
Wären dann äh alle ein Zimmer haben, in dem sie pennen. Und dann bin ich halt auch abends da lang gegangen und dann steht halt dran, welche Redaktion das ist und habe gesagt, hallo,
Ich bin jetzt auch hier und da sagen alle, geil, endlich ein Neuer da. Der hat noch was Neues zu erzählen. Wo kommst du her? Wer bist du? Setz dich. Äh willst du ein Stück Pizza, willst du was trinken? Es ist total lustig, wie man dann halt ganz schnell alle Leute kennenlernt.
Oder was halt für mich absolut irre war, also CNN ist wie immer mit einem exorbitanten Aufwand da und die haben dann gesagt, hey ja, willst du mal gucken, wie wir die Sendung machen?
Ja natürlich haben sie gesagt, ja komm mit ins Studio, hier dass die Regie, wenn du ruhig bist, kannst du dich mal daneben setzen. Dann konnte ich da echt irgendwie bei CNN sitzen, wie die ihre Sendung machen, wo ich dachte, wie geil ist das denn
Kannst ruhig Fotos machen, kannst du auch posten, ist kein Geheimnis, was wir hier treiben,
so Leute wie äh Christiane Amampur oder oder so, die laufen dann da rum und sagen, ey, hallo, wer bist du denn? Wie geht's? Alles gut?
Man denkt, okay, das ist äh also so so die die quasi die Stars in diesem Bereich,
laufen da rum und freuen sich, dass sie einen sehen und reden lustig mit einem. Und sagt, okay, das ist schon irgendwie,
also sozusagen sind alle ebenbürtig. Es ist nicht, ich bin aber der Große da und der ist nur Freelance und der da drüben ist bei Fox. Nee, es sind hallo Kollegen.
Was auch so 'ne sehr angenehme Welt dann schafft.
Was heißt großer Aufwand für Sie denn?
Dutzende Leute ähm Unmengen. Also ich es sind also sie haben im Prinzip ein gesamtes,
Studio mit allem an Technik angekarrt und allem an Sicherheit und allem bis hin zu Maske und Ersatzmaske und was da alles zugehört. Also,
Wenn man da durch läuft, denkt man echt, man läuft durch eine große Nachrichtenredaktion, Tischweise und alles was zum Studio und Producing und Schnitt und allem drumrum gehört,
Also äh so dass die keinen Koch mitgenommen haben, lag nur daran, dass der im Hotel war, glaube ich, aber äh,
Also so wie wenn du so Copy und Paste dein Büro nimmst und einfach darüber machst mit allen mit allem, was dazu gehört. Ähm Wahnsinn.
Also mein Eindruck war, die meisten haben auf jeden Fall eine Basis, vor allem auch die deutschen äh Fernsehsender, glaube ich, alle in Levis in Kiew selber sind nicht alle.
Ganz, ganz wenige. Ähm die ARD ist sogar noch nach uns angekommen. Das war leider so ein bisschen,
der Leute immer, dass also sozusagen als ich dann ankam, haben sie gesagt und wieder sind mehr Berlin Story News Korrespondenten da als ARD, weil wir das jetzt schon dreimal bei den vergangenen Kriegen hat und dass die so ein Running Gag ist oder,
wie man's sagen soll, also sozusagen die Messlatte, okay, Berlin, Story News hat mehr Leute als die ARD wieder vor Ort. Alles klar, wir haben wieder einen Punkt erreicht. Hallo Eno.
Was ich auch ein bisschen lustig finde, aber es ist halt auch irgendwie traurig oder ja ich denke mit dem.
Müsste nicht sein, ja.
Sie doch eigentlich, wo ich denke, da ist eine Menge Leute keinen Bock auf den Job haben, total verständlich. Aber mit dem Budget, was sie haben, müssten sie doch die finden, die das,
Machen oder machen wollen, also die wirklich sagen ich meine umgekehrt CNN hat da,
die hat halt irgendwie hala Gorani, Clarissa Award, Christiane Amampon, was Sophia wirklich große Namen der Szene sind,
und die waren alle da oder also zeitweise und dann wieder hin und her aber so,
Wir reden halt wirklich von den richtig Großen, die dann immer wirklich mit so einer ganzen Entourage kommen, mit der sie reisen.
Und die kriegen's hin und das ist privat und aus Amiland dann denke ich, ich zahle gerne meine meine Rundfunkgebühren hier, weil ich die Idee von Wir-Zahlen,
damit die Regierung nicht die Medien im Griff hat sozusagen. Das Konzept finde ich immer noch super exzellent,
aber dann sollen sie bitte auch da sein. Das ist halt der Punkt.
Und dann sind da halt und halt immer Bildzeitungen, muss man halt sagen, Paul Ronsheimer ist irgendwie immer der Erste, der da ist und der Letzte, der geht,
sagt, okay, das heißt, ich kann mir überlegen, ob ich im Bild TV quasi live Berichterstattung von allem habe, was da abgeht.
Oder ich mache die ARD an und lese die Agenturberichte. Also die AD mir vorliest. Ey eigentlich so von der Idee her müsste es doch andersrum sein.
Ist halt auch irgendwie und und dann hört's halt auf mit also dann gibt's natürlich deutsche Freelance die da sind und die ausländischen Sender war ich sozusagen als fauler deutscher Mensch, deutsche Nachrichten konsumieren will,
ist die Welt klein, also es gibt da noch von Weltenkollege, von Spiegel zum Beispiel Christoph Reuter, der auch immer, also der ist nicht da, wo's knallt, der ist fünf Meter weiter.
Also ähm der war in Afghanistan, alle waren in Kabul
Christoph Reuter meldet sich aus den entlegensten Gegenwarten, sagt, ich denke, da ist irgendwie die Hölle los und der sagt, oh, es geht, aber ja
Jetzt halt auch, der tingelt sozusagen durch die krassesten Dörfer im Don, was gerade so von Dorf zu Dorf und schreibt seine Artikel,
Alle sagen, wie zur Hölle bist du dahin gekommen und wie gedenkst du wieder rauszukommen? Äh also es gibt so einzelne so Leute wo man sagt Hut ab.
Aber so in der Masse fehlt's halt und das ist ähm dafür haben wir doch diesen öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk mit,
den theoretisch mit den Möglichkeiten, die er dann aber bei so was oft nicht ausfährt.
Ja haben wir ja auch schon mal beklagt, als wir äh über Hong Kong gesprochen haben. Ähm.
Jetzt war's so dann nochmal drei Tage in Kiew. Was kriegt man denn dann äh mit, wenn man da in so einer Luxushotel, Journalisten äh heißt es halt abhängt so. Also ich meine wie.
Worauf konzentrierst du dich dann? Ich meine, wie macht man so schnell, du hast ja jetzt nicht schon Quellen, die jetzt seit Wochen auf dich warten und.
I think zum einen der Hauptpunkt, was ich halt immer wieder sage, ist selber da sein, dann sagen die Leute, ja ja, hey, ich war genau da, wo die Scheiße passiert ist, weil ich,
da war und weil ich im richtigen Moment auf der Autobahn war. Ja, eine Menge Zufälle. Aber nur, weil ich da war. Also so das ist der Hauptpunkt sei erstmal da,
und dann ergibt sich eine ganze Menge. Und dann eben mit den Kollegen darumsitzen.
Äh das ist halt auch spannend. Also halt ähm jetzt sozusagen die die Leute, mit denen ich da viel zu tun hatte, waren halt CNN und Bild.
Dann sitzen die da rum und erklären mir eine Stunde lang die Lage in aller Ruhe und nehmen sich die Zeit. Wo ich denke, das ist halt auch irre, weil die haben echt anderes zu tun,
Ähm also entweder können Sie einfach sich in ihrer Berühmtheit suhlen und irgendwie mit ihren Fans chatten oder sie schreiben ihre Berichte oder sie machen ihre Sendung.
Nee, sie sagen, okay, was äh sollen wir dir grob sagen, was hier los ist und wie was hier ist? Also wo ich auch immer denke, es ist unglaublich geil, wie diese Szene funktioniert. Das glaubt man kaum.
Dann war halt klar OK, ist vorerst sicher, also sieht in diesem Moment sicher aus äh so.
Weil es ja im Prinzip jetzt genau der Zeitpunkt war, werden wir auch gleich noch mal drüber sprechen wo dieser russische Abzug begann.
Genau. Also ich bin sozusagen man könnte so sagen hinter den Rücklichtern der Panzer hergefahren, also so im.
Du kamst und die Russen sind zurückgewi.
Kommt. Berlin Story News ist auf dem Anmarsch. Genau und.
Schnell weg bevor noch die ARD kommt.
Genau, genau,
das war dann halt so äh also sozusagen genau der Moment wo man sagte okay also im Prinzip jetzt ist es vorbei in diesem Moment wo ich hier bin und die haben gesagt na ja,
jetzt weiter im Osten oder eben Maria oder so, je nachdem, wo man hin kann und wie und genau das waren so,
deren Schritte grade was wo was ist der letzte Millimeter bis zu dem wir noch gerade eben können um zu sehen was los ist und.
Wobei er ist die Präsenz in Kiel wahrscheinlich auch immer aufrechterhalten wird, einfach durch die Nähe zur Regierung und so weiter, ne.
Genau und so äh von da aus kommt man dann relativ gut ja in die anderen Sachen rüber oder na ja je nachdem aber ja und.
Äh dann habe ich gesagt, okay das halt Rakiff und so, das ist nix für mich, weil wie gesagt, ich kenne mich in der Gegend da nicht gut aus. Und allein Kiew war schon gewagt eigentlich da in dem Moment hinzufahren.
Das war ja überhaupt nicht klar, dass die Situation sich so entspannen würde zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo du da hin kommen würde.
Wie gesagt, bis wir auf der Autobahn an dieser Kreuzung war, war noch nicht klar, ob die Autobahn vor uns wirklich frei ist oder ob wir da nicht durch können oder ob das noch umkämpft ist. Also es war wirklich auf gut Glück hin und dann sich durchfragen.
Es gibt halt andere Gegenden, also gerade Kurdistan, da würde ich sagen, ach da fahre ich bis dahin, wo's knallt, weil ich kenne mich aus, ich kenne die Lage, ich kenne die Gruppen, also ich ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich's gut einschätzen kann.
Der Ukraine nicht. Das heißt, dann war der nächste Punkt, okay, dann gucken, wie ist die Lage jetzt in Kiew? Weil ähm.
Nur weil man sieht, die russische Armee zieht sich zurück. Davon weiß man immer noch nicht, wie's jetzt in Kiew aussieht. Also sind wir einfach rausgegangen.
Sind durch Kiew spaziert. Haben dann gesehen, okay, das erste was aufmacht sind die Bars. Ähm da waren schon wirklich so russische Armee seit einem Tag weg und hey Irish Pub hat geöffnet und wir haben Livemusik. Wollt ihr reinkommen? Also denkt,
Okay.
So wie wie in Berlin, wenn die ersten Sonnenstrahlen hier irgendwo ein äh fallen im Frühling. Dann auch sofort wird der Strand ausgerollt.
Oder so früher wie beim 1. Mai so, okay der Molli ist vorbei, gut Tür auf, Stühle wieder raus, weiter geht's,
und ähm und das war da halt auch so und man dachte, okay, es war im also,
Sagt, es hat einen so erinnert an so einen Weihnachtsspaziergang, also auch weil's anfing zu schneien, also so was auch irgendwie im April ein bisschen kühl war,
aber es war kaum jemand auf der Straße und so vereinzelt spazierten Leute so ziellos rum und ab und zu hatte so eine Bar auf oder ein Café oder ein kleines Geschäft, das war so Kleinkram, so hier eins, da, eins.
Ähm dann gab's halt überall noch diese riesen Straßensperren,
Wir haben die dann zum Teil auch fotografiert, also einer am Mai da, also so an dem berühmten Platz, sodass quasi der Location-Shot. Hier ist eine riesen Panzersperre direkt an dem Rübenplatz. Da kam auch sofort Soldaten, haben gesagt, hey, kein Ding.
Aber bitte postet's nicht. Ähm also nicht jetzt, weil wir wissen nicht, ob wir diese Sperre noch brauchen, ob das wichtig ist, also bitte also wenn wenn's irgendwie geht,
haltet euch zurück mit Details. Er sagt, ja, total verständlich, also in dem Fall echt absolut nachvollziehbar und vor allem, sie sagen nicht, du darfst nicht oder mach kein Foto, sondern die sagen, hey, bitte,
so responsible this close, ne? Sei sei vernünftig mit diesen Informationen. Du weißt selber, wie wichtig die sind. Das fand ich aber auch ganz angenehm, dass sie nicht sagen, du darfst nicht oder es geht nicht, sondern dass sie sagen, wir verstehen, dass es relevant sind, aber Vorsichten.
Und deswegen haben wir da auch eine Menge von den guten Bildern nicht äh sozusagen gepostet, wo man sagt, boah, das hätte Klicks gegeben. Aber ja, ist es nicht wert,
Das fand ich auch spannend bei den anderen großen Medien, denen wird ja oft vorgeworfen, dass sie so sensationslüstern sind und jeden Scheiß auf Bauschen. Wenn man dann aber da ist und sieht, was sie jeden Tag an Storys nicht bringen, also Wahnsinns-Stories, wo sie sagen,
Nee, geht nicht. Ist ähm.
Gefährdet Menschenleben hier. Wir können wir können nicht jeden Scheiß bringen, nur weil der gerade gute Klicks bringt. Das ist richtig viel, was in echt durch die Lampen geht äh oder auch so eine Sache,
wie viele Kollegen da gestorben sind. Ähm also Journalisten, wo die Leute auch sagen, ja klar kannte ich den. Wir haben ja jeden Tag hier gefrühstückt. So das ist das Journalistenhotel, also.
Hier waren die Leute und,
Das ist halt auch so, hm man veröffentlicht nicht die Namen von Kollegen, bis die Familie informiert ist. Also so würde niemand tun. Also niemand vor Ort. Und dann gab's halt zwei Fälle.
Wo Medien in Europa, also die keine Kollegen vor Ort hatten, die haben dann die Story veröffentlicht mit dem Namen,
Und alle, die vor Ort waren, haben die Fresse gehalten und das zurückgehalten. Und dann haben die halt auch gesagt, also zum einen, man tut's nicht,
zum anderen sozusagen die, die dabei waren in diesen Scoop zu nehmen, das als erste zu berichten und dann noch,
Familie sozusagen über Google News zu informieren, dass ihr Kind tot ist,
richtig schäbig. Also das sind so die Sachen, mit denen da auch niemand was anfangen kann. Das finde ich auch spannend wie bei all diesem schnell noch und klick geiler halt und was wir halt überall hier in den Medien haben,
Das ist dabei immer noch so ein Grundkonsens gibt mit aber das nicht. Also die Linie übertritt man einfach nicht, egal wer.
Was ähm konntest du denn dann über die Lage vor Ort und was du jetzt auch teilen kannst ohne jemanden zu gefährden ähm dann herausfinden, also wie schätzt du die Situation in Kiew jetzt ein?
Also jetzt gerade ähm relativ gut, also sozusagen jetzt in in diesem Moment,
die große Frage ja war ja kommen die Russen zurück und kommen sie zurück nach Kiew oder was passiert jetzt und das ist auch ganz interessant, weil niemand so einen richtigen Tipp abgeben will. Also sonst,
in jedem möglichen Krieg, Sarah, jetzt läuft's so, jetzt läuft's so, sind wir uns ziemlich sicher und da sagen alle mal abwarten. Wahrscheinlich.
Würde's jetzt einfach einen ewigen Krieg im Donbass geben, so so ähnlich wie Bürgerkrieg quasi.
Aber niemand ist sich sicher, dass äh Putin nicht doch noch mal äh einen Angriff auf Kiew macht, weil irgendwie da vertraut jetzt niemand drauf, dass das nicht passiert,
Besonders interessant auch fand, war halt, wie viel der sozusagen der Einfluss auf den Krieg von westlichen Staaten ist.
Hm, also ich meine, Deutschland hat ja geguckt, was haben wir seit mehr als 30 Jahren nicht mehr gebraucht,
sowie wie die Kabelkiste, die man unterm Schrank hat und sagt, okay, welches Kabel brauche ich echt gar nicht mehr, das kann ich doch mal der ukraine schicken. Also,
Wenn ich wenn ich ich glaube, dass das VHS äh Kabel vom Camcorder, das brauche ich echt nicht mehr, das kann ich jetzt mal dem Selensky geben,
halt die Amis und die Briten in,
exorbitanten Maß ja wirklich Frachtflugzeug, weise mehrere am Tag, da Waffen einfliegen. Äh wir haben auch Konvois gesehen von den Waffen, also weil die halt relativ offen da fahren und dann einfach so einen so einen Wagen mit Blaulicht davor haben.
Und jeder weiß, da kommen jetzt neue Waffen.
Aber halt auch Leute von westlichen Armeen, die vor Ort sind, ähm wo wir auch gesagt haben, seid ihr jetzt offiziell hier? Seid ihr privat hier? Es gab ja diese Headline von der britischen Armee, seien Leute.
Äh also sozusagen unerlaubt abwesend und dann in der Ukraine aufgetaucht,
Wo man sich auch beim Lesen fragt, was was genau wollt ihr jetzt sagen,
Ihr habt die verbummelt und jetzt laufen sie in der Ukraine rum oder was wie genau ist dieses diffuse Statement vom britischen Ministry of Defense zu zu verorten?
Sag mal so hundertprozentig ließ sich das nicht klären, aber man kann sagen, ja, da laufen,
englischsprachige Leute rum, die dann sehr genau instruieren drück doch mal auf den Knopf, dann fliegt der Panzer besser in die Luft oder so,
Das war halt auch am Anfang so, da haben alle gesagt, hui, die äh Ukrainer sind aber ganz schön gut mit dem Panzerabwehrwaffen und dann sickert halt durch, ja gut, weil sie da halt so ein paar,
sagen wir mal gut ausgebildete Soldaten an der Seite hatten aus dem Westen, die ihn halt genau gesagt haben, wie's funktioniert. Ähm,
Was halt irgendwie so eine Grauzone ist, weil die NATO sich ja oder NATO Mitgliedsstaaten sich nicht wirklich einmischen wollen, aber sie liefern Waffen und es ist bekannt, dass da auch Leute von ihnen sind und hin und her,
oder das ist das, was man dann am Ende so den Foug of War nennt, also so den den Nebel des Krieges so, irgendwie ist da was, aber es ist vielleicht so ein bisschen verschwommen und so hundertprozentig kann jetzt keiner sagen, wer war, wer hat am Ende wo auf welchem Knopf gedrückt, aber dann war der Panzer halt kaputt
Ähm und.
So diese Details mitzubekommen, wenn man da ist und sagen, ja, ich habe diese Gerüchte gehört und dann läuft da jemand rum, der englisch spricht und man sagt, hey, was treibst du eigentlich hier? Ich habe von dir den Nachrichten gelesen. Das ist halt das Spannende, was man dann vor Ort hat,
und ähm das sind halt so die die wichtigen Erkenntnisse und halt sehen in Levive zum Beispiel war ganz normales Straßenleben, Geschäftdaten auf, Cafés hatten auf, Leute liefen rum, äh so in Kiew.
Nicht. Da war ähm da war halt nix los. Da war äh da waren keine Menschen,
War nur die Frage sind keine mehr in der Stadt oder kommen die nicht raus? Also so das war auch interessant, weil auch die Leute von vor Ort uns gesagt haben, das ist schwer zu sagen, weil hm sie kennen halt ihre Bubble.
Und so im Durchschnitt hatten wir das Gefühl, die Hälfte der Leute sind aus Kiew geflohen und die Hälfte ist da. Aber das ist halt so.
So aus der eigenen Bubble eigene Umfrage. Die haben gesagt und die Hälfte, die noch da ist, die gehen jetzt erstmal nicht raus, weil erstmal ein, zwei Tage abwarten, ob's ruhig bleibt,
und dann wird's wahrscheinlich auch wieder nach und nach äh mehr mehr Straßen leben und so geben. Und das ist aber ganz ähm ja das ist im Prinzip, warum man hingeht, einfach um diesen Eindruck zu haben. Noch eine Sache, die.
Wie viel Frauen hast du denn gesehen und wie viele Kinder?
Wie nicht. An der Grenze viel, aber das kann man noch sagen, genau als wer eingereist sind, also als wenn dieser Schlange standen da kam ein.
Sozusagen ein kontinuierlicher, kleiner Strom von Menschen zu Fuß in die Gegenrichtung, also nicht nicht wie irgend also,
nicht Unmengen Leute, sondern so eine Familie und noch eine Familie und noch eine Familie mal so hintereinander. Es waren eigentlich immer junge Frauen mit kleinen Kindern, wirklich,
90 Prozent waren irgendwie Frauen, keine Ahnung,
fünfunddreißig oder jünger würde ich mal schätzen mit Kindern im Grundschulalter so ganz grob. Und das war so der der absolute Hauptteil der uns da irgendwie entgegengelaufen kam.
Das was man so am Hauptbahnhof in Berlin.
Genau. Genau, also was so wirklich das Bild so prägt.
Und die Männer dürfen zum Teil nicht ausreisen, da also sind so verschiedene Limitierungen, ähm aber zumindest alle, die ich getroffen habe, wollten auch nicht,
Die haben gesagt, nee, nee, ich will ja, dass also was bringt's denn, wenn wir gehen? Wir wollen ja, dass unser Land bestehen bleibt,
und haben gesagt, klar, soll meine Familie weg, aber ich bleibe hier. Also da ist auch hm sage mal schwierig zu sagen, wie viele würden gerne weg, aber können nicht, aber so und wie viele wie viele bleiben gerne da, weil sie wirklich helfen wollen.
Und.
Äh das war aber auch in der Stadt dort. Also wir haben da auch junge Frauen und sogar ein paar Kinder gesehen, aber wirklich wenig. Also dieser eine Kneipe, die auf hatte, da saßen halt ein paar also so Leute jünger als dreißig drin, auch Pärchen und so,
und haben da irgendwie Kaffee getrunken und es gab
irgendwie so eine Hand voll Kuchen, also wahrscheinlich so selber gebacken oder so auf die Schnelle. Ich fand's geil dieses Bild überhaupt. Also quasi es sind gerade eben die Panzer weg und dann gibt's da Kaffee und Kuchen und der Laden hat auf. Also auch ein geiles Zeichen einfach.
Denke, das ist auch ein auch nach innen wahrscheinlich wichtig.
Normalität.
Normalität wieder erleben zu können. Ja. Auch wenn sie absurd ist.
Ja und und halt klar, einer muss zuerst aufmachen und dann sehen die anderen derart auf, da machen sie auch auf, also.
Ich gehe von aus, dass jetzt in in diesen Tagen das so plötz, plöp immer weiter aufgeht.
Und halt auch die Versorgung, also die Weinkieft zum Glück nie völlig zusammengebrochen. Also es war nie, war ja nie richtig eingekreist. Es war es wurde immer schwieriger,
aber sie war nie völlig abgeschlossen. Das heißt, im Prinzip gibt's da auch alles. Es muss jetzt wahrscheinlich nur einmal aufgefüllt werden.
Aber auch die Supermärkte, die wir gesehen haben, also so kleine, es hatten so also wie so nicht Riesensupermärkte, sondern halt so die mit der kleinen Auswahl auf und da war aber auch alles in den Regalen grundsätzlich drin, also die waren nicht leergefegt, sondern es sah in Ordnung
aus. Also die hatten offensichtlich noch genug im Lager, dass sie nachfüllen können, also nicht nicht wie in so einer Geisterstadt.
Und jetzt kommen halt äh die ganzen Kolonnen wieder mit Ware rein. Das heißt, das dürfte ganz schnell gehen, dass da auch wieder halbwegs Straßenleben exist.
Wobei es Kiew ja auch nie wirklich abgeschnitten war, es den Russen nie gelungen ist, wird die Stadt so umzingeln.
Genau. Genau, also wir haben halt gesagt, es war schon schwieriger. Natürlich sagst du nicht, ich bestelle mal die Fässer Bier für nächsten Monat, äh wenn du nicht weißt, ob die Stadt dann noch da ist. Also deswegen es ist so langsam leergelaufen und jetzt füllt sich's halt wieder auf.
Mhm. Hast du mit ähm vor Ort auch sprechen können.
Also viel. Also wir haben einfach Leute auf der Straße angesprochen, gesagt hey wir sind Journalisten, wie geht's? Was los? Und ähm.
Haben die dann vor allem darauf wollten die dann erstmal wissen, wo du herkommst.
Ja genau, also erstmal die jüngeren Leute sprachen oft Englisch und zum Teil exzellent Gutes, also welten besser als meins,
und zum Teil so OK oder was dann auch warte warte der spricht Englisch hier komm mal her red mal mit denen aber so immer sie wollen halt erstmal sprechen also nicht dass sie sagen hey ich verstehe dich nicht tschüss.
Alle was zu erzählen.
Hey, wo kommt ihr her? Wie seid ihr hergekommen? Ah, die Straße ist auf. Okay, okay, interessant und was macht ihr hier? Also ist auch richtig interessiert, also freuen sich, ne?
Auch gefragt, was machst du beruflich? Ist dein also äh gibt's deine Firma noch? Äh wie geht's deiner Familie und so?
Und die Storys waren eine relativ ähnlich. Also die meisten haben gesagt, einen Teil der Familie ist weg. Also die Kinder sind weg, die jüngeren Frauen sind weg, die Oma ist weg. Das war so der Klassiker oder auch,
Oma und Opa wohnen noch in ihrem Dorf, weil die wollen nicht weg, egal was ist, die die bleiben da.
Ähm die Kinder sind oder nach Levis oder so in Sicherheit halt alle so Richtung Westen.
Zum Teil aber auch äh dass sie gesagt haben, ja Berlin, ja ja, da ist meine, da ist meine Schwester grad oder meine Frau oder oder sage ich, aber in einer anderen Stadt hier äh Köln äh oder irgendwie sowas aufm Handy nachgeguckt,
Ähm also äh ja ganz interessant und dann halt, die haben gesagt, ja also so quasi Arbeit ist seit ein, zwei Monaten zu, also seit Kriegsbeginn bei den meisten zumindest. Bei manchen lief auch noch irgendwas.
Aber auch, dass die gesagt haben, ja, es ist halt auf Pause. Also auch der Chef sagt, ne, ne, wir sind nicht weg, aber im Moment ist halt Krieg, aber so also sozusagen,
Nicht, dass sie sagen, alle hauen ab und keiner kommt wieder und die Sache ist hier durch, sondern dass alle sagen, ja, jetzt gerade ist schlecht.
Aber warte mal einen Moment abwarten. Wie wie wie geht's jetzt weiter? Also immer eigentlich so mit der Perspektive, ja ja das geht schon weiter. Also ich gehe nicht weg, sondern meine Familie kommt zurück,
anders als ich's von Leuten in Syrien gehört habe, die sagen ja ja die der Rest der Familie ist schon in Deutschland und ich komme jetzt nach,
Erhalt in der Ukraine eher, ja die sind jetzt quasi in Sicherheit geparkt und dann kommen die halt zurück, wenn's wieder gut ist. Also das war so von allen, die die klare Perspektive, das ist jetzt eine temporäre Sache,
Jetzt geht's gerade ein bisschen aufwärts, aber ganz ruhig abwarten.
Du, dass das eine generelle Einstellung ist oder jetzt grade genährt von der Entwicklung, dass die Russen um Kiew abgezogen sind.
Also ich glaube jetzt gerade war's wirklich so noch die Euphorie von okay die sind weg. Also die haben auch alle gesagt, die kommen nicht jetzt wieder. Also nicht jetzt ist alles gut, sondern,
So jetzt mal durchatmen und dann aber die bleiben erst noch weg, weil gucken, was passiert. Aber per se schon, dass,
alle, mit denen ich gesprochen habe, gesagt haben, egal wie, am Ende gewinnen wir,
Also so vielleicht nicht im Dondorf, vielleicht nicht in also die aber die Sachen sind schon seit Jahren so halbwegs abgeschrieben, sondern,
Im Großen und Ganzen, also der signifikante Teil von der Ukraine, der gewinnt. Und dann können wir zurück nach Kiew, nach Leview oder in die Orte dazwischen,
aber das ist schon optimistisch waren, dass sie am Ende wieder nach Hause gehen alle.
Doch gesagt warum.
Sie haben halt gesagt erstmal, sie wissen wofür sie kämpfen, nämlich für genau das, dass ihre Familie nach Hause können, sagen, wofür kämpfen denn die Russen? Ähm.
Auch eine Stelle, da haben wir so einen abgeschossenen Panzer neben der Autobahn gesehen und dadrunter war so Metall irgendwie,
Dann sagte einer, ja, ja, das sind Matratzen, also so die Federn davon, weil,
Mal Zelt oder so gehabt zum Teil und die haben dann quasi zwischen den Ketten unterm Panzer gepennt. Also bis sie irgendwas ähm also die russischen Soldaten bis sie irgendwo ein Haus überfallen haben oder so, in dem sie gepennt haben.
Stell dir mal vor, du warst jetzt zwei Monate in dem Manöver in Belarus und hast im Regen, im Matsch unter deinem Panzer gepennt und jetzt kämpfst du hier,
Und dann musst du dir noch Essen irgendwie aus dem nächsten, aus der Tankstelle klauen und die Leute erschießen, die da arbeiten. Wofür kämpfst denn du dann und wie lange machst denn du das? Also da das ist keine Perspektive für das du erfolgreich bist,
Wenn du aber da wohnst und sagst, ich will, dass meine Familie wieder nach Hause kommt, dann hast du eine gute Motivation zu kämpfen,
und das ist glaube ich ein also ein sehr entscheidender Punkt an der gesamten Geschichte,
selbst wenn so ein russischer Soldat vielleicht völlig verblendet ist und er meint er steht auf der richtigen Seite, da hat er immer noch keinen Bock unterm Panzer Matsch zu pennen. Das äh also irgendwann sagt man, ha ja.
Egal ob ich auf der richtigen oder falschen Seite stehe, das ist scheiße.
Auch nicht mehr das, was und okay.
Hoffnungsvolle, überzeugende Art. So, ich denke, das ist ja auch so das Bild, glaube ich, was die Welt von der Ukraine äh bekommen hat, vor allem nicht nur äh aber auch eben durch den wir.
Auftritt hast du mit Leuten über Selenski reden sie über ihn? Ist es ein Thema?
Ähm also wir haben sie danach gefragt und dann leuchtet echt die Augen und die haben gesagt äh also die einen haben gesagt, der war immer schon geil und die anderen haben gesagt, der ist so ein Idiot, aber gerade ist der so geil. Also am Ende war's immer jetzt grade exzellent, egal ob sie ihn vorher mochten oder nicht,
Das fand ich so spannend. Also manche haben gesagt, ey der Typ, ich habe den nicht gewählt, aber geil ist er.
Ja viele gewählt, also ich meine 73 Prozent das war schon eine Ansage.
Genau aber halt selbst die, die nicht gewählt haben, haben dann gesagt, hm, aber jetzt gerade bin ich froh, dass er da ist. Also was ich auch, also,
auch, dass deine anerkennen können. Wo ich dachte, okay, frage mich so, also,
sehr weit ab jetzt nicht wirklich vergleichbar, aber was wir halt in den letzten Jahren immer wieder gehört haben oder sich so im Umfeld hätte, dass Leute sagten, nee, CDU echt scheiße,
aber dass die Merkel äh so sich für die Flüchtlinge eingesetzt hat, okay, dafür kriegt sie Punkte. Also so in der, dass sie sagen, also wirklich durch die Reihe haben die gesagt, geile Nummer,
und Klitschko, also sozusagen dann als Bürgermeister halt von äh Kiew, also die beiden, die ja so,
Aus der Außensicht ein geiles Team oder so sind. Das war halt auch interessant, weil die Leute vor Ort dann immer gesagt haben, ja ja, du weißt schon, dass die sich hassen, ne? Oder dass die politische Gegner waren und äh überhaupt kein gutes Wort füreinander hatten,
Aber jetzt stehen die Seite an Seite und sagen, ey hier ist Lava Ukraine und wir hauen die Sache aus dem äh aus dem Matsch,
also sozusagen nur gute Worte über über die gesamte Regierung, wo ich denke.
Ich würde gern mal wissen, wie das ist, wenn man sich über seine Regierung freut. Also was was mag das wohl für ein Gefühl sein? Ich.
Bin ja jetzt erst knapp 40. Ich kenne das nicht, wie das wie das sein muss, wenn man sagt, ist das geil hier. Ist das geil, was die gerade abziehen.
Okay, aber das korrespondiert ja so ein bisschen auch mit dem Bild, was wir, glaube ich, geliefert bekommen. Also ich das wäre jetzt auch so meine Vermutung gewesen, dass es so ist, so ist ja auch immer gut äh zu wissen und äh können wir ja vielleicht gleich mal so ein bisschen auch,
die innenpolitische Situation reden ähm du hast ja schon gesagt okay Klitschkkur Selensky,
Mich wundert das so ein bisschen, ehrlich gesagt. Ich meine, ich weiß jetzt nicht, was die so im Spezifischen für politische Dissenzen äh da haben. Vielleicht auch nicht so wichtig, aber ich meine, sind natürlich beides so.
Sind beide einfach die Prototypen von eigentlich nicht für den politischen Job äh geboren worden, bringen aber dann doch jeder auf seine Art.
Etwas mit aus ihrem früheren Leben, was in dieser aktuellen Situation dann doch äh sehr hilfreich zu sein scheint.
Vorhin im Vorgespräch schon kurz äh drüber gesprochen. Das ist natürlich bei Selenski seine ganze Schauspielerausbildung sicherlich kein.
Also sicherlich kein ist in der Art und Weise, wie er jetzt mit der Welt redet.
Und Klitschko natürlich auch mit seiner äh Weltöffentlichkeit, speziell auch dem Zugang zu Deutschland auch nochmal, wo er noch mal so eine besondere Popularität hat. Ähm ne und dann natürlich so auch so als,
Prototyp der starken Beschützer, ich meine,
mehr als Schwergewichtsweltmeister, geht da irgendwie auch äh gar nicht. Ja, dass dass die da so mit drin sind, aber auch so der von Selensky abgelöste Präsident äh Broschenko.
Ist ja auch mit im Boot. Also man hat schon das Gefühl, dass diese Allianz sehr sehr klar und sehr stark ist.
Auch was es da alles fürs für Gags gab, die so Anfängen mit, äh der Milchschnitteverkäufer und der Clown. Äh die treffen sich und irgendwie äh gewinnen jetzt den Krieg gegen Russland, ne?
Miesstätteverkäufer.
Hat Milchschnitte Werbung früher gemacht. Ja ja also deswegen also ich meine war Schauspieler hat auch so Klauenkram gemacht aber so wenn man's jetzt mal überspitzt darstellt, also die die Werbefigur für Milchschnitt und der Clown die kommen an und besiegen Russland,
Das ist schon.
Das ist schon wirklich die größte Niederlage. Ja, das das,
muss so muss so frustrierend sein für Wladimir Putin ausgerechnet von denen. Darüber hatte ich ja mit Pavel ja auch schon gesprochen, dass gerade der Selensky ich weiß nicht, hast du dir auch mal diese Serie gegeben äh.
Des Volkes.
Ganz schnell lizenziert dann oder das fand ich auch geil, wo ich dachte, hey, wieder ein Hoch auf.
Nur die erste Season, aber.
Aber trotzdem, wo ich dachte,
für so ein äh sagen wir äh langsam operierenden Apparat wie sowas wie Arte oder so, also mit diesem ganzen Drumherum, dass die da ad hoc sagen, okay, das Ding und ab in die Mediathek dachte ich schon okay, Respekt. Das war eine coole Nummer.
Und da habe ich's dann auch sofort gesehen, weil ich dachte, okay einfach, ich kann draufklicken, fertig. Ich muss nicht normal als Porridge oder so laden, aber ja.
Seasons, war in Season drei. Ich will ja wissen, wie das ausgegangen ist, damit ich weiß, wie das jetzt auch im.
Macht's hier in N an, dann siehst du wie's äh Season vier,
Ja, aber das dachte ich auch. Ja, irgendwie also so diese ganzen Zusammenhänge, das ist schon irgendwie lustig. Also er spielt einen Präsidenten und dann ist er Präsident, ne? Und ähm ja, was wir vorhin schon hatten.
Typ Schauspieler ist und weiß, wie er redet, wie er seine Mimik im Griff hat, wie er ordentlich dasteht oder wie er auftritt,
Das war halt hm nicht nervös wird, wenn er vor einem Parlament spricht oder einem anderen Parlament und auch wieder austeilt. Wo er sagt, so Leute, jetzt setzt euch mal auf den Arsch und ich erkläre euch, wo ihr Fehler macht.
Ich denke, dass äh also diese.
Also sozusagen diese positive Überheblichkeit oder wie man's nennen will. Dass er sagt, so Leute, ich ich regiere hier gerade die Welt, ähm nicht der Trump hat den Putin in die Knie gezwungen und nicht die EU. Ich war's,
Und ich erkläre euch jetzt mal, was ihr machen müsst. Oder halt dieser Spruch von ihm hier. Also so ich ich brauche keine Mitfahrgelegenheit. Ich brauche eine Knarre.
Glaube ich.
Emmo, genau. Genau.
Immer noch nicht so sicher, ob das nicht schon wieder so ein äh äh ja ja er hat er hat so etwas gesagt, ich muss ich werd's mal gleich mal nachschlagen, ne?
Halt wie mit, wer zu spät kommt, dem bestraft das Leben. Der Satz ist nicht gefallen, aber den kennt man noch.
Ja. Ja, den werden wir noch ewig erzählen, ne? Ja.
Ja, wo ich denke, der die die machen schon beide also sagen wir mal so, nicht nur, dass sie geil auftreten, sondern sie liefern ja auch. Also die Kombination ist halt, denke ich, so selten.
Ich glaube, der Spruch ist schon gefallen. Hier gibt's äh Videos von ihm, würde er das sagt. Also.
Noch besser.
Ja ja und T-Shirts gibt's natürlich.
Ähm auf der offiziellen Seite von der Ukraine, als ich so geguckt habe, Einreisebestimmungen, also sowas wie der Touristenverband. Kannst du auf der Startseite ein Shirt kaufen mit Russian Warship, go fuck yourself,
Also dass das irgendwo in Webshops auftaucht, okay, aber das ist dein Tourismusverband bewirkt geile Nummer.
Doch mal korrigieren. Die Washington Post ist nochmal diesem äh Zitat auch nochmal auf die äh Spuren hinterher gelaufen. Äh only events for this lineson annehmend US official äh.
Ja also ja also.
Mal sagen, es ist relativ gut belegt, dass er wahrscheinlich so was Ähnliches gesagt haben wird. Äh.
Ja. Ist ausreichend okay.
Ja, ja, okay. Mhm. Ähm ja.
Ist es gut festzustellen, dass es so etwas wie eine Innenpolitik äh auch noch äh gibt, so eine der,
Meldungen, die ich in den letzten Sendungen besprochen hatte, war so dieses Jahr, jetzt machen wir mal eine Steuerreform und so weiter. Also wenn so ein Land noch in der Lage ist, eine Steuerreform zu machen, dann äh ist noch nicht alles äh verloren.
Ja und auch muss man gefundene Panzer steuerlich deklarieren. Da gibt's ja offizielle Aussagen von wie genau deklariere ich einen russischen, gefundenen Panzer.
Ja genau und das äh darf man das dann behalten und so, ne? Ich glaube, die dürfen den dann sozusagen auch einfach weiter verkaufen, da die Bauern, die den aus dem Dreck gezogen haben.
Und wenn du aber als russischer Soldat überläufst, gibt's jetzt ja Prämien. Wenn du kommst, gibt's Geld, aber wenn du einen Panzer mitbringst, gibt's, glaube ich, hunderttausend. Wenn du ein Flugzeug mitbringst, fünfhunderttausend.
Wo ich auch dachte nehmen wir mal einen durchschnittlichen russischen Soldaten und die sitzen zu viert im Panzer und du sagst okay jeder kriegt fünfundzwanzigtausend, wenn wir jetzt da rüber fahren und aussteigen. Hm.
Gibt noch was, was das Ganze erst so richtig wertvoll äh erscheinen lässt. Gibt da auch noch einen ukrainischen Pass dazu, damit man dann halt auch gleich sich irgendwie absetzen kann, weil nach Russland will man dann erstmal nicht mehr. Mhm.
Wo ich halt denke, hey, wenn's hilft, ne? Alles gut.
Bevor wir vielleicht mal so diese ganze internationale äh Situation noch mal abklappern, ähm sollten wir vielleicht mal auf die gesamte militärische Situation in diesem Krieg blicken. Das machen wir hier eigentlich immer bei UKW
haben wir halt vor allem erstmal so über deine Reise und deine persönlichen Eindrücke gesprochen ähm.
Ich hätte mal sagen sollen, was heute überhaupt das Datum äh ist, das hole ich mal nach. Also wir nehmen jetzt hier auf am sechsten April zweiundzwanzig. Man konnte es jetzt schon so ein bisschen raushören.
Abzug der Russen aus den nördlichen und nordöstlichen Kampfgebieten scheint so weit abgeschlossen zu sein, also der Kampf um Kiew ist beendet, da wird jetzt Schritt für Schritt die ganzen Dörfer im Norden wieder ähm.
In ukrainische Kontrolle äh gebracht oder sind bereits unter ukrainischer Kontrolle. Das weiß ich jetzt im Einzelnen so nicht. Aber es sieht so aus, als ob dieser Rückzug so das erste ist, was die Russen irgendwie so halbwegs hinbekommen haben in diesem Krieg,
ging relativ äh schnell vonstatten. Das hätte ja auch also man sie haben's mit Sicherheit, ne, ganze Menge Gerät zurückgelassen, also insbesondere dieses ganze Schwere, schwer zu bewegende Gerät, so Flugabwehrsysteme sind, glaube ich, viel
zurückgelassen worden und ein paar andere Sachen.
Störsender, die so wirklich Hightech, Störsender, um westliche Aufklärungsflugzeuge zu stören, also so Premium-Sachen. Das war, glaube ich, schon kurz ja genau, genau.
Glaube ich schon vor zwei Wochen, das ist schon so ein Ding so so rum, da meinte auch irgendjemand das äh das ist glaube ich mittlerweile schon auf dem Weg zu den Amerikanern und.
In den Längle irgendwie in.
Sehr gefreut.
Auch so ein Punkt, das war nur so eine Nebenstory, die ich also geil fand, äh wie der eine Typ mit zwei Flaggen vier russische Panzer äh vernichtet hat,
und ähm das war im Prinzip so mit zwei Flaggen.
Mit vier Panzern, zweien ging der Sprit aus und sie blieben stehen. Dann sind sie mit den anderen Panzern so ums Dorf gefahren. In der Zeit hat er zwei ukrainische Flaggen je auf einen ihrer Panzer gesetzt. Und als sie ums Dorf rumkam, haben sie die gesehen und geschossen. Also haben sie ihre eigenen Panzer abgeschossen,
So, dann sind Sie aber weiter gefahren, weil Sie Ihre Panzer gesucht hatten, weil Sie Sprit holen, weil Sie nicht verstanden haben, dass Sie Ihre gerade abgeschossen haben.
Weiter rumfahren haben sie beide Panzer im im Matschfest gefahren, kamen nicht mehr raus und sind dann in der Nacht abgehauen. Und so haben sie mit zwei Flaggen zwei Panzer vernichtet und zwei erbeutet.
Oh Mann ey.
Und so Storys gibt's da ja zuhauf.
Ja ja zuhauf ist es alles so schwer zu verifizieren. Also auch so diese Behauptung.
Wenn ich im Raum äh ein wenig im Raum steht, dass die ukrainische Armee mittlerweile über mehr Panzer verfügt als zu Beginn äh des Krieges ist so ein bisschen schwer zu belegen, aber so ganz
unwahrscheinlich scheint es nun auch nicht zu sein, weil die Verluste sind schon äh sind schon riesig. Aber vielleicht erstmal eine die Gesamtsituation. Also der Kampf um
Kiew ist jetzt erstmal beendet. Er ist es im festen als auch im Osten, also im Nordwesten als auch im Nord äh Osten. Das teilt sich ja dadurch diesen äh,
äh dann gab's halt äh außerdem noch diese Attacke auf Sumi. Das liegt so ein bisschen äh schon in die Richtung äh Sharkief. Äh,
Auch die Stadt konnte er nie eingenommen werden. Auch da scheint es jetzt erstmal vorbei zu sein. Das heißt, die Russen ziehen eigentlich weiträumig ab und damit äh ist sozusagen ja auch.
Belarus ein wenig raus aus dem Spiel, weil im Prinzip jetzt von Weißrussland aus.
Wenn sich das jetzt nicht noch mal äh ändert, derzeit quasi kein kein Krieg auf ukrainisches Gebiet rausgeht mit der Ausnahme, dass
ja diese Long-Range-Missheit äh sicherlich von dort noch losgeschickt werden, Angriffe auf Levis et cetera äh gehen glaube ich von dort aus, wenn sie nicht auf äh von Transnistrischem Gebiet aus.
Ja genau.
Werden. Das ist ja dann nochmal dieser andere Bereich in Moldawien, den sich Russland ja auch äh vor Jahren schon so ein wenig unter den Nagel gerissen hat. Aber generell kann man sagen Bodentruppen,
derzeit nicht von Belarus aus an. Erinnert jetzt an der Situation nicht viel, aber es fiel mir jetzt gerade selber auf, dass.
Ist schon relevant. Also ich meine, wenn sie jetzt auf der gesamten Länge bis kurz vor Polen da irgendwie Ärger machen würden, dann würde es ja permanent,
Probleme geben, aber äh ja, ich glaube, das ist auch vielleicht ein bisschen Vorteil von diesem Riesenland, Kief ist interessant. Levie,
Aber ganz ehrlich, wie viel Meter Matsch man einnimmt, ist für einen Krieg am Ende nicht,
Also wenn du wenn du drei Dörfer einnimmst oder nicht. Also es ist für die Leute, die da leben wichtig, aber für den Krieg ist es nicht relevant.
Und ja, sie brauchen halt Kiew.
Im Nordwesten ist ja ist ja irgendwie nix, ne, da ist ja keine großen Städte oder so.
Und selbst also selbst wenn man halt so auf Google Maps guckt, die paar Städte, die aufpoppen, wenn man dann genauer guckt, sagt man, na okay, zehntausend Leute, zwanzigtausend Leute vielleicht mal fuffzig da, es ist so das ist nicht der Punkt sozusagen. Damit hast du nicht das Land übernommen, ne?
Genau. Das heißt, alles konzentriert sich jetzt auf den Osten und natürlich auch noch auf den,
Süden. Ich würde mal mit dem Süden mal anfangen wo äh natürlich alles von der Krim ausging und die alte äh Grenze in Anführungsstrichen
die ist ja so dominiert von so,
da ist viel ja, da ist viel Wasser irgendwie, deswegen ist das so ein bisschen so eine natürliche Grenzung gewesen. Ähm dann gibt's aber eben weiter nördlich, eben bei der Stadt äh
gibt's eben noch mal so einen breiteren wie soll man das nennen, Kanal ist schon fast äh untertrieben, also das ist schon,
größeres Flussbecken, was da halt diese Bereiche äh trennt, alles auch sehr sehr sumpfig. Da gibt's eigentlich nur eine größere Brücke rüber, die wohl noch steht, wo aber auch schon gemunkelt wurde, dass die Russen, die äh.
Sabotiert haben zum.
Ja nicht nur Feminta, also sozusagen zur Sprengung vorbereitet haben, weil es könnte ja sein, dass wenn sie Kerstin verlieren.
Was durchaus sein kann, weil die kriegen da eine ganze Menge äh Druck und haben natürlich die üblichen äh Probleme, die sie überall sonst auch hatten
sie dann sagen, okay äh scheiß drauf, dann äh hauen wir hier die Brücke weg, weil ihr kommt jetzt über diesen Meeresbereich, über diesen Flussbereich
nicht so ohne Weiteres äh rüber und dann können wir diesen ganzen Südbereich
den wir quasi nördlich der Krim noch dazugewonnen haben, der so an sich jetzt erstmal nicht wertvoll ist, außer dass es natürlich dann viel Agrarland ist. Da können wir auch noch mal drüber reden. Äh ne, könnte man sozusagen an der Stelle den Zugriff der Ukrainer
unterbinden.
Ja und also nur zur Vorstellung dieser Flussbereich oder dieser Fluss- und Schlammreich, da reden wir vor ein paar hundert Metern bis ein Kilometer Breite oder so. Also es ist ja,
sozusagen nicht so ein bisschen, wo man dann sagt, okay, dann bringe ich die Klapprücke vorbei oder die Ponton-Brücke und dann ist ist das alles irgendwie gemacht, sondern das ist ja wirklich so eine so eine Strecke, was man auch nicht mal eben
reparieren kann, wenn die Brücke weg ist.
Ja ja, also ich weiß nicht, die die die engste Stelle gut es gibt gibt da noch eine zweite Brücke, aber es es muss dann mindestens so ein Kilometer muss immer mal irgendwie überbrückt werden. Das ist nicht mal soeben gemacht, ja.
Definitiv. Ja, genau. Also,
Und das ist natürlich eine der Hauptangriffsrouten, dort sind sie ja relativ weit vorgestoßen und versuchen nach wie vor Mario Pohl vollständig einzunehmen, dort ist der Widerstand extrem. Da ist es den,
Ukraine offensichtlich auch längere Zeit gelungen, obwohl die Stadt komplett.
Umzingelt ist und das ja jetzt schon seit zwei, drei Wochen.
Trotzdem noch in irgendeiner Form Hilfslieferungen und Versorgung zu liefern mit Hubschraubern, aber das ist natürlich dünner. Dementsprechend äh sind die Zustände in dieser Stadt nach wie vor schlimm und trotzdem dauert's aber,
sehr, sehr, sehr lange die Stadt einzunehmen, das heißt russische Truppen sind dort nach wie vor kräftig gebunden und können den sonstigen Krieg nicht ein,
greifen. Das ist natürlich schon ein Gewinn für die Ukraine, auch wenn natürlich die Situation in Maropol.
Da ist ja nix mehr. Also die Bilder, die man ja sieht, ist halt wie Aleppo oder so. Also da steht kein Stein mehr, ne,
Hat viereinhalb Jahre oder was gedauert, die Belagerung und sie haben die Stadt trotzdem nicht bekommen, ne? Also so also,
Das meine ich halt mit mit deinem mit deinem Panzer über ein Feld fahren. Das kann jeder und dann sagst du, ich habe zehn Kilometer gut gemacht,
aber eine Stadt einnehmen, also und auch wenn du die Stadt zerbomst und den Trümmer legst, dann hast du sie immer noch nicht eingenommen, dann hast du sie kaputt gemacht. Aber in der Stadt einnehmen,
schwierig genug, eine Stadt einnehmen, wo die Bevölkerung gegen dich ist, kannst du eigentlich vergessen. Also das ist fast nicht möglich. Also.
Äh ich war in in Kirkuk, in im Irak,
als äh der IS versucht hat, die Stadt mal anzugreifen. Da werden halt kurz nach dem Angriff da,
Der IS in dem Fall kam halt wie immer mit ihren Pick-ups und hat rumgeschossen und so. Die waren halt im Großen und Ganzen nicht die hellsten.
Und die sind halt durch so eine Art Zufahrtsstraße gefahren und,
Waffendichte in der Gegend ist so gefühlt so wie hier die Autodichte in Deutschland oder so, das heißt so selbst die letzte Oma hat sich aus dem Fenster gehangen mit der Kalaschnikow und die haben einfach diesen ganzen Konvoi zerlegt von vorne bis hinten,
nicht mit großen Waffen, sondern einfach weil jeder aus dem Haus geschossen hat,
und als wir dann ankamen, war so viele Leichen von denen auf der Straße, dass wir nicht mal mehr drumrum fahren konnten, sondern dass wir warten mussten, bis aufgeräumt waren. Die kamen dann wirklich mitm Müllwagen, um die abzuholen und haben das gefilmt,
weil sie damit nicht korrekt bestattet wurden und das in diesem Warn von diesen ganzen bescheuerten IS-Leuten total wichtig ist, dass du deine Jungfrauen kriegst,
Wenn du aber von einer weiblichen Mitarbeiterin in Müllwagen geladen wirst, kriegst du die nicht. Ich habe die Details nicht verstanden, aber das war so im Groben die Sache.
Oh Mann.
Ähm und da habe ich halt gedacht, ah, so sieht das aus, wenn du Straßenkampf versuchst und keiner dich mag. Ja, das und,
Wo ich denke ähm ja, du kannst halt Cruise Misside schicken, du kannst Artillarie schicken und dann sind die Leute tot,
aber wirklich gewonnen hast du die Stadt immer noch nicht. Dann hast du am Ende einen statt also ein Stück Trümmerhaufen äh eingenommen, aber da hast du nicht mal was von. Also
eigentlich entweder willst du ja Gebiet gewinnen oder Bevölkerung oder halt Agrar- oder Industrieanlagen oder irgendwas,
aber eine Stadt zerschießen und dann sagen, jetzt ist meine also da hast du ja in keiner Richtung ein Erfolg,
Also du hast, du hast genau nichts gewonnen am Ende. Das ist da halt, denke ich, also du hast eine Menge Schaden, eine Menge Tote verursacht, aber gewonnen hast du gar nix.
Ja, also was sich die Russen davon versprechen, ist ja ohnehin frei zur äh Definition ausgeschrieben.
So oder so macht es aber auf jeden Fall den Eindruck, dass sie diesen Gürtel rund um dieses Asow Schmerz,
in irgendeiner Form noch mit in ihren Verführungsbereich bekommen möchten und es ist halt einfach nun mal so, dass diese russischen.
Staatsräson einfach vor allem erstmal äh alles über Territorien definiert und da ist dann irgendwie eine platte Stadt mehr oder weniger äh.
Kaputte Städte haben sie jetzt schon genug.
Ja, das wird sich schon irgendwie finden. Wohnen wollen sie da ja nicht, sie wollen das ja nur äh kontrollieren.
Das wird sich noch zeigen, also sicherlich ist Mario Pohl jetzt schon eine der Städtenamen, die halt so in diese unrühmliche Reihe von Aleppo und Stahlengrad äh Liniengrad et cetera äh eingereiht werden müssen, wo einfach,
äh bis zum äußersten gegangen äh ist oder zumindest gerade gegangen wird.
Bleibt aber quasi diese ganze Offensive. Nirgendswo sind sie ja so weit vorangekommen. Das hat aber vor allem damit zu tun, dass sie ja im Prinzip schon große Teile des Donbass schon hatten, dass sie Luhansk und äh Donezk
in äh ihrer Kontrolle hatten, aber davor da steht halt,
nicht nur die Ukrainische Armee an sich, sondern dort steht auch wirklich der Teil der,
am meisten Erfahrung,
haben scheint. Die Ukrainer hat sich ja nach diesem ganzen Krim und äh Desaster äh militärisch komplett neu aufgestellt
Ergebnisse sehen wir jetzt, also äh extrem modernisiert, einfach ihre ganze Kommandostruktur den Bedingungen angepasst und damit bisher den Russen, die einfach,
gedacht haben, wir machen jetzt hier mal Business as usual. Äh äh mal gezeigt, was eine Harke ist und dementsprechend ist der Widerstand groß, aber,
Es ist immer so schön, was was was andere äh mit Eleganz und Technik machen, das machen die Russen mit viel,
und äh äh noch haben sie irgendwie viel
ist ein bisschen schwierig einzuschätzen, wie viel sie von allem noch haben, wie viele Leute sie noch haben, wie viel wie viel Gerät sie noch haben, die Verluste sind enorm, aber sie haben halt irgendwie auch viel eingemottet und haben halt irgendwie alles äh raus
grad was äh zu haben war, zumal aber.
Es nach wie vor in den Berichten so den Anschein hat, als ob sie nicht verstärken, weil sie eigentlich auch nichts mehr haben, mit dem sie verstärken können.
Ja, das ist ja das Komische so formal, haben die ja eine Million Soldaten ungefähr und dann haben sie noch die Reserve und dann haben sie noch im Zweifel diese Milli also theoretisch kommt man da auf eine gut siebenstellige Zahl, was sie
auf dem Papier hätten und sagt, okay klar, du brauchst einen Teil zur Grenzsicherung und du brauchst einen Teil, alles klar, aber der Rest also irgendwie also,
Wenn du dir ein Blatt Papier nimmst und das zur Zeit aufschreibst, sagst du, da fehlen doch 100.tausend hier, 200tausend da oder was, also wie wie sind diese Zahlen jetzt genau zu deuten? Irgendwas,
Irgendwas stimmt doch hier nicht oder irgendwas sind die nicht da? Gab's die nie? Sind die keine Ahnung? Also.
Bei dir Gesamtzahl teilt sich natürlich auf in alle, die gerade Wehrdienst machen
alle, die halt wirklich jetzt fest verdingte Soldaten sind, also die quasi Zeitsoldaten sind, die sich da äh vertraglich gebunden haben. Das ist das eigentliche Kämpfen, die her. Dann gibt's halt die ganzen äh Reservisten und was so theoretisch noch alles mobil machen kannst, nur ist es ja in Russland so
eben für einen Krieg zwar alles mobil machen kann, aber für eine spezielle
Terroroperation da muss man eben mit dem normalen ähm Personal arbeiten und das ist so ein bisschen diese Zwickmühle, abgesehen davon, also ich meine er kann halt nicht mobil machen, weil dann würden die Russen halt denken so wie.
War aber nicht in den Nachrichten.
Deswegen hatten ja auch erst alle auf diese Operation gewartet, also dass man sagt, jetzt haben uns die Ukraine angegriffen, jetzt haben wir Krieg oder was man sich da ausm Arsch ziehen kann,
und ähm das fand ich auch ganz spannend, auch die Rolle von den US Nachrichtendiensten.
Die hatten ja auf dem Tag genau den Krieg vorausgesagt erst und dann kam er an dem Tag nicht. Und dann gab's diese guck mal, die sind alle so doof.
Sagt, hm nee, die haben mehrere exzellente, hochrangige Quellen verbrannt, indem sie dieses Datum genannt haben, aber damit haben sie's den Russen vermasselt, dieses Datum zu nehmen,
Und dann halt, als sie gesagt haben, hier Achtung, Fleckoperation mit ähm Biowaffen oder Chemiewaffen, haben sie weitere Quellen verbrannt. Und da dann gesagt, aha, sind die doof, die gab's gar nicht. Ja, weil's dadurch, dass es.
Offen gelegt wurde, ist die Sache nicht mehr nutzbar. Und dann haben sie sich halt irgendwann gesagt, okay, immer wenn wir die Welt waren, werden wir ausgelacht und horha, sind die doof.
Und es hilft keinem signifikant. Also können wir es uns ja auch sparen, die zu wahren, weil mit den Briten und so, die anderen, die helfen, tauschen sie eher ihre Information,
Aber da muss man ja nicht mehr die Welt groß waren und seine Quellen verbrennen, wenn am Ende eh also die Idee war ja und dann kommt die EU und sagt Scheiße, jetzt helfen wir,
Und stattdessen ist die EU da sehr zurückhaltend und dann haben sie gesagt okay, dann brauchen wir auch keine Quellen weiter verbrennen und wichtige Informationen preisgeben, wenn,
Wenn ihr eh nix macht.
Denke, dass die Strategie gescheitert ist.
Also dass sie sozusagen waren und jemand drauf anspringt, ja, weil,
die für Häma auch von deutschen Politikern bekommen haben, wo ich denke, seid doch froh, also wir haben nicht mal einen sinnvollen Nachrichtendienst bei da keinen, auf dem Niveau,
Wieso sich noch öffentlich darüber lustig machen, wenn sie sowas tun,
ähm und dass man dann irgendwann keinen Bock mehr hat und sagt, gut, diese Sache, die Welt zu wahren ist gescheitert. Ja, weil ich meine, wir sehen ja, wie viel die EU, sagen wir mal, zusammenhilft,
wie viel die Amerikaner und die Briten helfen und da es ein arges Missverhältnis, weil so selbst gesammelt aus der EU kommt, sagen wir überschaubar viel Support,
Also wenn wir jetzt so von Waffen und allem reden, was in die Ukraine geht, also hier werden Flüchtlinge aufgenommen, klar, aber.
Sozusagen, wenn die Flüchtlinge nicht produziert werden würden, wenn man vielleicht vorher reagiert hätte.
Dann äh wäre allen mehr geholfen und stattdessen sind's wieder die Amis und halt in exorbitanten Mengen liefern und wir gucken halt, was wir an Gammel Hardware über haben.
Ja gut, ich meine in Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass die USA und Großbritannien aber auch die Schutzmächte für dieses Budapester Memorandum waren, mit dem ja eigentlich der Frieden dort gesichert werden sollte, ist es vielleicht ganz angemessen, dass sie sich jetzt hier auch entsprechend engagieren.
Das Jahr, aber wo ich denke zum anderen, warum waren wir denn nicht eine Schutzmacht oder die anderen? Wir haben doch ein Rieseninteresse daran, dass die Ukraine keine Atomwaffen hat oder insgesamt, dass weniger Leute Atomwaffen haben.
Auch wieder bequemer und sagt, au ja, rüstet ab
Und jemand anders ist bitte die Schutzmacht. Also so wie immer Deutschland spielt halt keine Rolle in der Oberliga. Äh,
Man hätte ja auch einfach sagen können, wir helfen oder wir oder wir oder andere bieten uns an.
Zumindest könnte man behaupten, dass äh aber jetzt ein Nachdenken,
ein Prozess schon in Gang getreten ist. Bleiben wir vielleicht nochmal kurz bei der militärischen Situation, das abschließen zu können, weil ich glaube, diese internationale äh Betrachtung ist dann für den Schluss noch mal ganz interessant.
Jetzt gibt es quasi so diese Vermutung oder,
So könnte, so könnte man das sehen, ja. Okay, die Russen ziehen aus dem Norden ab, weil sie gesehen haben, wir kommen da nicht weiter. Wir kriegen Summe nicht eingenommen, wir kriegen Kehlschuhen überhaupt,
eingenommen? Was sollen wir uns da weiter äh unsere Elite einhalten und die sonstigen äh Leute zusammenschießen lassen? Das kostet uns alles nur Geld. Und was weiß ich, was da noch für Faktoren spielen. Es gab ja auch immer diese Berichte von den,
Sabotagen in Weißrussland im Gleissystem,
ist ihnen an der Stelle auch sozusagen die ganze Versorgungssituation auch noch auf die Füße gefallen und die Summe aus allem hat gesagt, okay, alles klar.
Am Ende da ist für uns nichts mehr zu holen, konzentrieren wir uns jetzt hier auf den eigentlichen Landgewinn.
Das bedeutet, sie machen nach wie vor Druck jetzt eben nur noch aus Russland auf Sharkief, wo es militärisch,
glaube ich, nicht so gut aussieht, aber eben vor allem dieser ganze Donbassbereich. Und natürlich der nördliche Krimbereich, also ich weiß nicht, wie man diese Region nennt, da oberhalb äh der Krim, aber na ja.
Also zwischen Krim und dem Fluss so irgendwie, ne.
Und ähm da geht's auf jeden Fall heiß her. Da gibt's eine ganze Menge äh Kampfgebiet, sehr viele Konfrontationen und durchaus auch,
vorrücken der der Russen und das sieht natürlich alles sehr bedrohlich aus und so äh wird halt viel darüber geredet, okay wenn's den Russen jetzt gelingt, da irgendwie die Lücke zu schließen. Ich denke mir nur,
Sie diese Lücke da schließen wollen und wir reden jetzt irgendwie von auch so von so einer Lücke, die mal eben wieder so 160 Kilometer äh lang ist. Ähm,
Also das wird jetzt sicherlich auch nicht unbedingt besonders einfach. Ähm.
Und eine Landgrenze. Also ich meine diesen ein bis mehrere Kilometer breiten Fluss als sozusagen militärische Grenze, okay. Das versteht auch ein Laie, dass da irgendwie nicht ein Panzer rüberhüpft oder so.
Aber quer durchs flache Land? Also das geht unter friedlichen Nationen, aber das ist schon eine schwere Nummer.
Aber ist auch für die Ukraine schwieriger, weil natürlich, weil es eben wirklich vor allem flaches Land ist, mit sehr wenig Ortschaften und man sich da eben nicht so gut geria-mäßig ver
kann, wie das jetzt im Norden äh
war. Andererseits beginnt natürlich jetzt auch der Frühling, Wälder und Bäume, die halt noch kahl waren, haben jetzt viel Grün. Also es verändern sich verschiedenste äh Faktoren,
Dafür taut's natürlich jetzt noch wieder ein bisschen auf, das weiß ich glaube ich im Süden ist es aber nicht ganz so sumpfig wie im Norden,
Also, viele Faktoren, die wir jetzt auch gar nicht weiter äh bewerten können, um's mal vielleicht mal zusammenzufassen, alles konzentriert sich jetzt eigentlich auf den Süden und auf den Osten und im Süden kann es durchaus sein, dass die Ukraine noch ein bisschen äh Druck macht und vielleicht,
auch die Chance noch gegen zu halten, weil ein Problem der Russen ist halt nach wie vor nicht äh behoben oder,
nur ein Problem. Ist eigentlich eine ganze Kaskade von Problemen. Es ist die Motivation, die wir schon angesprochen haben, die wird nicht besser. Die ganze Logistik ist eine totale,
der Zustand ihres Geräts ist äh nicht gut so. Das ist alles altschlecht gewartet. Äh sie haben enorme Probleme, überhaupt ihre Soldaten gefüttert zu bekommen. All diese ganzen Dinge,
dazu eben eine sehr viel bessere Inteligence im Prinzip halt die ganze NATO gegen gegen die Russen, ohne dass die NATO zugibt, dass sie irgendwie,
da ist so, ne, ist es eigentlich schon ein kleiner Weltkrieg, oder?
Äh ja, deswegen nennen sie's ja mal Weltkrieg zweieinhalb. Also so.
Das habe ich noch gar nicht.
Mhm. So da sagen wir, der Begriff taucht immer wieder auf, Weltkrieg zwei Komma fünf. Also so so noch nicht ganz, aber auch nicht so ganz nicht, ne? Also so.
Also wenn man mal aufschreibt wie die beteiligten Nationen.
Dann hast du ja Ostblock, Westblock sozusagen, eine Menge drumrum, also alle, die irgendwie dazugehören zu so einem klassischen Weltkrieg, sind jetzt schon dabei in irgendeiner Form.
Äh ja.
Und es gibt halt echte Kampfhandlungen und es gibt irgendwie äh Tote und Gräuter an. Also du hast sozusagen, wenn du so eine Checkliste machst, ab wann ist es ein Weltkrieg? Hast du jetzt eigentlich schon den den signifikanten Teil davon?
Ja, was ist dann auf dieser Checkliste?
Ich würde halt sagen, also mindestens Russen und Amis beteiligt. So, okay. Und halt so, sagen wir mal, nicht ganz festgelegt, aber noch mehr Länder, damit's Weltkrieg ist. Man sagen ja, Dutzend oder so, haben wir jetzt ja bestimmt, die irgendwie.
Das war nicht die ganze EU, sind ja schon mal irgendwie 26 plus dann.
Dreißig oder so insgesamt sagen wir ganz grob die beteiligt sind und sagen ja dann hast du tatsächlich aktive Kämpfe. Nicht irgendwie Wirtschaftskrieg oder so sondern nee Panzer gegen Panzer aufm Boden?
In einem fremden Land, also nicht, dass sie über die Grenze schießen, nur jeder, sondern ne, ne. Ähm das da würde ich sagen, das sind schon so die die maßgeblichen Teile davon. Ähm.
Ja und auch die weltweiten Sanktionen haben natürlich dann auch ihren Teil dazu beigetragen. Das ist natürlich dann.
Atomwaffendrohung. Ich glaube so ob derzeit also dass Putin ja irgendwie sagt er kann's nicht mehr ausschließen oder gab's dort so eine schwammige Formulierung oder man,
Man müsste drüber nachdenken oder irgend so einen Schrott gab's also irgendwie so so ein nicht eine nicht eine direkte Drohung, aber auch nicht mehr komplett ausgeschlossen irgendwie so, ja.
Na ja. Tja, was denkst du? Nee, vielleicht bleiben wir noch mal, bleiben wir aber vielleicht mal bei den Playern. Ja. Ähm die USA.
Ist in gewisser Hinsicht wieder in eine alte für sie stolze Rolle äh
zurückgefallen. Auf einmal sind sie wieder die Guten und die Weltpolizei und äh können auch ihre Fähigkeiten
einbringen, auch wenn diese selbst verordnete Zurückhaltung mit wir kämpfen nicht aktiv on the Ground gegen die Russen noch steht.
Na
Ich würde sagen, es bröckelt. Also ich glaube, würde man jetzt mal genauer durch die Ukraine gehen? Ich glaube schon, dass man da Amis findet. Ähm also aktive Soldaten, das äh aber halt nicht in Masse. Aber.
Nicht nicht kämpfend.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, würde ich sagen. Also es gab da durchaus Gerüchte, also ich meine, das ist immer.
Ja, aber keine Bataillone, die jetzt irgendwie na ja.
Sondern so einzeln. Hier und da mal den Panzer nach rechts und links drehen oder mal am Rohr ein bisschen schrauben und sagen, jetzt mach mal, jetzt triffst du besser.
Aber gut, ich meine, was haben die Amerikaner mit russischen Bauarten zu tun, weil da kommen ja keine.
Ja die haben aber schon Ahnung von. Die haben ja äh,
Also alles, was sie an russischen Sachen in die Finger kriegen, gucken sie ja schon sehr genau an und wissen auch, wo die Schwachstellen sind und so was. Also die haben ja die haben ja schon Abteilungen, die im Prinzip alles, alles sich angucken, was aus Russland kommt und drüberfliegen.
Okay.
So wie Hacker und Süßatmen.
Aber vor allem ist es halt.
Auch die politische Rolle, die jetzt sozusagen in äh in den USA,
eine große kann man kann man ja in man kann es ja nicht so richtig trennen, also die die Weltpolitik der äh Amerikaner ist natürlich auch eine ähm eine militärische und ich weiß nicht siehst du das?
Siehst du, dass dass es wirklich nochmal zu einer konkreten,
Konfrontation kommen, würde man sehr generell dieser Konflikt, der glaube ich, grade auf Deutschland noch mal besonders herabgegnet,
ist ja dieses Ding mit wir sind ja angetreten oder wir wir verstehen uns selbst äh auch die EU,
als Friedensbewahrer. Und wir wollten ja immer den Krieg in Europa verhindern und wir haben uns irgendwie Nobelpreise äh Friedensnobelpreise umhängen lassen, weil wir ja so geil den Frieden geschützt haben und über fünfzig.
Wir mal den Kosovo dazu, ne?
Aber gerade das war ja dann auch,
Die Argumentation, wir müssen dort eingreifen, auch wenn es äh von der UN keinen Beschluss gibt, weil sind ja Acrusities, ist ja hier äh Völkervernichtung
et cetera. Wir sind ja quasi ethisch moralisch gezwungen, einzugreifen, weil man kann ja dem Sterben nicht äh zusehen, dem Völkermord.
Auslandsrepränica. Äh.
Auch nicht so gut funktioniert, aber am Ende war natürlich der militärische Einsatz und wirklich der aktive Kampf gegen Serbien war ja dann letzten Endes genauso äh formuliert und ich würde sagen, ich kann das halt auch nachvollziehen
So, ne, das war
umstritten und Pazifisten sehen's anders und Pazifisten sehen's jetzt wahrscheinlich auch wieder anders. Nur äh das war die Argumentation und das war ja im Prinzip dann auch eine,
klare Marschrichtung. Nur da waren halt die Russen nicht unmittelbar beteiligt. So, es war gab halt keine Atommacht, deswegen das war das ja relativ einfach.
Ja und sagen wir mal so, in dem Moment, wo die Amis mit Bombern und so hoch gerüsteten Kram gegen die Serbea kam, war auch,
Also du kamst mit einer deutlichen Übermacht an, was deine Gewinnchancen einfach mal exorbitant erhöht haben, ne.
Ähm also ich meine gut, ein bisschen Wissen, ob's gut war dann als die Serben mit diesem ich glaube 40 Jahre alten Rader an Stalls Fighter detektiert und abgeschossen haben, weil die Amis sich so siegessicher waren, dass sie halt,
reihenweise Fehler gemacht haben. Man denkt, ja so, so lernste.
Aber was.
Denkst du, kann hier noch passieren? Also kann es noch so ein Tipping Point geben? Ich meine, Mario Pohl ist schon krass. Diese Geschichte ist krass. Es wird wahrscheinlich jetzt auch noch,
Beim ganzen,
Abräumen des Nordens noch sich weiter verkrassen und wenn man erstmal das sich genauer anschaut, was jetzt gerade im Osten passiert, also es ist ja einfach an an schlechten Nachrichten.
So einige und man könnte immer wieder sagen so oh jetzt ist aber so ein Punkt erreicht, jetzt ist aber so ein Punkt erreicht, aber keiner könnte das jetzt irgendwie quantifizieren oder auch nur qualifizieren, wann eigentlich jetzt wirklich ein Punkt erreicht ist
ja auch immer über allem derzeit noch dieses Dogma ist mit ja wir wollen ja verhindern, dass noch mehr Leute in diesen Konflikt mit reingezogen werden. Ja also zynisch könnte man sagen, na ja wir opfern jetzt sozusagen die ukrainische
Bevölkerung damit nicht noch weitere Bevölkerung sterben.
Ja auch, dass die Ukraine ja fast nicht auf russisches Gebiet zurückschießt,
Wo ich auch denke, ist ja auch immer eine Entscheidung. Gehst du jetzt, keine Ahnung, schießt du einfach eine Cruisemithall auf Moskau und sagt, hier, guck mal, wie das ist. Ähm,
oder lässt du's? Und ich meine, bis auf diesen einen Angriff so ein Hopp über die Grenze nach Beugegrad haben sie sich ja auch damit zurückgehalten, wo ich auch denke, das sind ja auch irgendwer muss ja mal gesagt haben, ja, lass uns das nicht machen, sondern so hey Vorsicht,
so nicht nicht den Tiger noch pieken, sondern mal gucken, ob er von selber weggeht.
Mit dem Tiger dann weniger zu tun, als dass sie sich generell einfach auch klar in dieser Verteidigungsrolle äh ins Licht stellen möchten.
Nur ich meine so, wenn der Tiger anfängt, dich anzupiksen, sagst du dann, hey, ich piek ihm mal ins Auge, nur so zum Spaß oder sagst du, ich stelle mich mal ruhig hin und gucke, ob er weitergeht, ne?
Ich denke, da sagen die auch, wieso eskalieren ohne Sinn, ne, also so so zum Beispiel klar, Sie können jetzt einfach mal gucken, schaffen wir's mitm Kampfjet bis Moskau oder wenn wir zehn schicken,
Aber warum? Also um aus Prinzip zu sagen, haha, können wir auch, nee, also sie sind schlau genug, nicht so doof zu sein wie der andere, ne?
Ich denke auch mit diesem was was passiert noch oder was ist der Tipping Point? Ich find's,
also dadurch, dass Putin, also Putin habe ich immer gedacht, egal was er macht, er hat einen guten Plan. Also weil er eigentlich ja ein schlauer Typ ist, also kein guter Typ, aber eigentlich weiß er sehr genau, was er tut und was die Folgen sind. Zumindest bisher immer,
auch.
Wenn's aus westlicher Sicht auf ist, der doof. Man sagt, nee, nee, aus seiner Sicht war das schon eine ganze Menge Dinge waren aus seiner Innensicht total schlau und richtig gemacht. So äh größter Scheiß aus unserer,
aber,
Das hier ergibt jetzt keinen Sinn mehr, aus keiner Perspektive irgendwie richtig. Also da diese Drohkulisse aufgebaut hat, das hat noch Sinn ergeben, dass er sagt erstmal Nord Stream durchkloppen, bisschen so die Muskeln spielen lassen und sagen, hey hey, ich könnte ja,
Aber dieser Angriff ergibt keinen Sinn und deswegen finde ich es so schwierig, weil ich denke also wahrscheinlich ist ja.
Weil dies ja immer mit diesen Daten und diesen symbolträchtigen Sachen haben, dass auch für den 9. Mai,
wo sie den, wo die Sowjets ja eigentlich den Sieg über die Nazis feiern, wo ja die Ukrainer zugehören, dass Russland da irgendwie ähm einen Erfolg braucht.
Jetzt ist die Frage, kann er als Erfolg verkaufen? Hey, wir haben zwei Ampelkreuzungen im Luhansk übernommen, die wir vorher nicht hatten,
Ähm oder Willa Kiew, also überlegt er sich nochmal was völlig Bescheuertes, dass sie in aller Gewalt noch mal versuchen in einer Woche bis Kiew zu kommen oder so.
Ich denke nicht,
Aber ich würde auch nicht drauf wetten, dass er's nicht tut inzwischen mehr, weil's halt so ich finde so schwer einzuschätzen ist, was äh,
wie beim Film Bang Boom Bang, das Zitat fällt mir immer ein, was weiß ich, was in dem sein Hundehirn vor sich geht. Ähm so ich kann's,
Kann's nicht mehr richtig einschätzen, wohin er geht.
Gut, das können wir vielleicht nicht einschätzen, aber ich würde mal sagen gerade eher unwahrscheinlich, dass sie äh jetzt da nochmal genau dort reinmarschieren, wo sie äh schon richtig im Schlamm hängengeblieben sind und.
Wetten?
Glaube ich ehrlich gesagt um um gar nichts so, ne. Ich versuche mir bloß äh zwei also,
mich interessieren zwei äh Perspektiven. Natürlich die militärische Perspektive kann die Ukraine mithilfe des Westens ist sie so stark?
Und ist sie auch wird sie auch ausreichend unterstützt, um die Russen zurückzudrängen. Wo ich sagen würde.
Macht so den Eindruck, als könnte das eine Option sein,
Und andererseits, wie groß ist eben das Eskalationspotential für den Westen sich noch mehr zu engagieren sollte das Ziel nicht erreicht werden könnten?
Ja und auch was heißt jetzt zurücktrennen? Weil wir inklusive und Krim oder nicht? Also ich meine das ist ja auch noch ein entscheidender Punkt, so wo ähm wenn man jetzt sagt inklusive Krim, dann sind wir auf einem ganz anderen Niveau.
Ich denke erstmal geht's auf jeden Fall erstmal um und das sagt ja auch Selenski. Er sagt ja,
Das, was vor dem 2undzwanzigsten November Februar war oder vierundzwanzigsten, das muss jetzt erstmal.
Gesichert sein oder.
Also drunter machen wir gar nix so, ne? Bevor er äh gehen wir auf gar nix ein
So, ne. Da müsst ihr einfach schon mal weg sein. Was nicht heißt, dass er jetzt den Anspruch auf die
in irgendeiner Form zurückgenommen hätte, ne? Aber er ist halt soweit Realist zu wissen, dass jetzt über diese Zeit natürlich die Russen sich da in einer Art und Weise eingegraben und gefestigt haben, dass das,
Bier ja selber meint, dann dann sind wir wirklich im dritten Weltkrieg. Das war zumindest seine Formulierung in dem Interview, was er diesen äh russischen äh Journalisten gegeben hat.
Auch die Bevölkerung immer der entscheidende Punkt. Was will die Bevölkerung auf der Krim,
Wenn die Bevölkerung gerne zu Russland gehören möchte, zum signifikanten Teil, dann kann Salenski tun, was er will,
umgekehrt halt mit Kiew, wenn Kiew nicht zu Russland gehören will, also so, das denke ich ist auch so ein bisschen ein Punkt, was genau wollen die Bevölkerungsmehrheiten in den Gebieten, weil von denen hängt's halt.
Sehr weit ab, was überhaupt möglich ist.
Das haben wir natürlich nicht unbedingt nicht den Eindruck, dass man diesen Wunsch, auch derzeit ordentlich.
Ja genau, genau.
Bekommt. Das ist natürlich das andere Problem. Aber vielleicht noch mal die Sache mit diesem Eskalationspotenzial und was könnte sozusagen den Westen dazu bringen, seine Meinung noch mal zu ändern? Ich denke, was auf jeden Fall helfen würde, ist,
Ähm,
eine noch weitergehende sichtbare, spürbare Schwächung der Russen, also wenn man sie ohnehin schon so an so einem Punkt hat, wo sie eigentlich nur noch den letzten Schubser brauchen, um die Klippe runterzufallen, dann äh.
Sicherlich eine höhere Bereitschaft, das auch zu tun, aber letzten Endes ist es ja dann auch,
eine ja generelle Entscheidung. Man muss sich sehr sicher fühlen in seinem eigenen Grenzen.
Und was dann?
Man muss den NATO-Konsens haben.
Was passiert dann? Also bricht Russland auseinander, weil da zehn Leute sagen, hey ich habe da eine schlaue Idee, ich wollte meine Republik immer schon frei haben oder,
werden sie total demokratisch und auch so diese Kettenreaktion. Was ist dann zum Beispiel in Syrien, wenn auf Seite von Assad auf einmal Russland weg wäre? Also sagen wir mal Russland klappt irgendwie um, ist irgendwie am Boden, wie auch immer.
Was hat das dann für Folgen da, wo Russland jetzt irgendwie, also das finde ich ist so schwierig, weil keine Ahnung, was weiß ich.
Auch in Georgien, ja. Klar, das hat natürlich Implikationen und äh inwiefern Russland selber auseinanderklappen kann,
weiß ich nicht, aber Sie haben natürlich das Problem, dass so wie es jetzt aussieht, Sie vor allem,
bei allem, was ihr ihren ihren inneren Zusammenhalt äh sichert, sich selbst enorme,
Schwächungen zugefügt haben. Die wirtschaftlichen Sanktionen führen dazu, dass die einzelnen Regionen sich eher voneinander abkoppeln, weil's halt so ein bisschen die russische Tradition ist, immer so den Local Gover äh für alles verantwortlich
machen, wenn's scheiße läuft. Das ist dann halt nicht Moskau, auch wenn's letztlich daran liegt,
Also werden jetzt alle schön irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass äh ja, wenn Essen knapp ist, dann wird das Essen halt nicht exportiert und äh so weiter.
Importiert, was es jetzt wohl losging, die machen Stockpiling, die Gouverneure, die Geld in der Kasse haben, sozusagen auf Kosten der Nachbar,
Gegenden. Also der eine guckt noch, wo er irgendwie Klopapier und Mehl und Öl kauft, damit's bei ihm da ist und er der gute Gouverneur ist,
Ich meine halt das alte Problem, es kann nur einer gewinnen, äh können können nicht alle Gewinner sein, ne. Also so dass die unteren dann so zuerst wegklappen.
Genau und dann natürlich auch Infrastruktur. Ich meine jetzt, wo ihre ganze äh Flug.
Infrastruktur eigentlich.
Von außen betrachtet, nicht länger als ein halbes Jahr kann das gut gehen so, dann ist einfach der Wartungszyklus durch. Sie kriegen ihre ganzen Airbusse und Boings, die sie jetzt äh zurückbehalten haben, obwohl sie das eigentlich nicht dürfen.
Auch international überhaupt nicht mehr fliegen können.
Halt wie mit dem Iran bisschen. Also die die hatten das ja mit. Sie haben keinen Zugang mehr zum Markt und dann okay du kannst Teile tauschen. Du kannst ausschlachten und,
Äh ja und irgendwann und ich meine, Sie haben ja theoretisch in Russland immer eine eigene Luftfahrtindustrie, wo ich erst dachte, gut,
Und dann guckt man, ach so, aber die die Zulieferer sind im Westen. Also weil sie's eben nicht mehr oder nicht mehr, sie könnten's vielleicht noch selber, aber warum, wenn du's woanders kaufen kannst.
Aber sie bauen vor allem halt nur spezielle Frachtflugzeuge, et cetera, kleinere äh Personen, Flugzeuge, aber diese klassischen Airliner für den Passagiertransport, dass es halt auch dort alles Airbus und.
Suche euch Superjet, also geht aber ja eben, die da haben sie ein paar von und das skaliert nicht der Bau, also so.
Genau. Und sie kriegen eigentlich gar nichts mehr produziert. Also die Wirtschaft ist halt einfach äh extrem geschwächt, weil sie enorm von technologischem Zulauf, ähm abhängig sind und das ist halt etwas.
Also selbst wann denkt, die die haben doch Rüstungsindustrie und selbst die hängt inzwischen von westlichen Lieferanten ab.
Keine Panzer mehr gebaut zum Beispiel.
Also wo man denkt, das war doch das Einzige, wo man hier mal Angst vor hatte, wenn die Russen mit ihren 100.000 Panzern kommen, nicht mal die können sie mehr bauen. Also haben noch, aber ja.
Und das ist natürlich dann aus aus Sicht des Westens natürlich dann insofern eine wünschenswerte,
äh Situation. Also es ist jetzt so ein bisschen so eine zynische Betrachtung. Ich greife das jetzt nur auf, weil ich das auch so äh gelesen habe grade, sagen wir mal so in so,
Superlinken Kreisen dann so ja ihr wollt ja den Krieg nur verlängern, weil ihr wollt ja äh Russland sozusagen weiter abnutzen, das ist für euch ja gut und dann verkauft ihr auch eure ganze äh,
eure Rüstungsindustrie profitiert et cetera.
Man muss doch sagen, dann gibt's am Ende weniger Panzer. Das wäre doch in diesem Sinne oder nicht.
Ich will ja gar nicht dafür dagegen argumentieren
sage nur, das das sind solche äh Betrachtungsweisen, die jetzt hier mit ins Spiel kommen und es ist ja nicht so, das ist jetzt nur eine Gedankenlinie gibt, sondern es geht immer so eine komplette Matrix von Möglichkeiten auf und von unterschiedlichen Meinungen, aber was glaube ich
klar ist, dass egal, wie das jetzt ausgeht. Die Russen,
die Schwächung Russlands, die militärische Schwächung und die wirtschaftliche äh Schwächung Russland die stark zusammenhängt, wird weitergehen,
völlig unabhängig davon welche äh in Anführungsstrichen Erfolge sie jetzt hier noch äh feiern können und selbst wenn's ihnen irgendwie gelingt
Diese Gebiete jetzt äh weit zu auszuweiten. Sagen wir mal da wirklich
na bis zum Jepper werden sie nicht nicht vorstoßen können, aber wenn sie irgendwie sagen wir mal den Donbass vollständig und diese nördlichen Teil ähm der Ukraine einnehmen würden.
Das müssen sie ja dann auch noch halten.
Sagen wir mal durch irgendein Wunder, übernehmen Sie die gesamte Ukraine militärisch.
Dann hätten sie immer noch die ganzen Sanktionen, sie werden immer noch isoliert, sie hätten also irgendwie selbst sozusagen der aus ihrer Sicht vielleicht potenziell bestmögliche Fall,
Sie immer noch von der Welt abgeschnitten. Also da denke ich auch, was wäre denn selbst dann neuer Ziel? Also sozusagen,
Realistisch ist es nicht, aber selbst dann kommt ihr nicht mehr auf die Füße und jetzt, wie du sagst, was halt so am wahrscheinlichsten ist, so den Donbass oder dann einen großen Teil vom Donbass,
Was habt ihr dann? Also irgendwie was wie geht's dann weiter? Das ist halt wie also schlimmer als Iran von den Sanktionen ja. Ich meine Iran ist das blöde Iran kannst du nicht mehr ernsthaft sanktionieren, weil die leben solange mit den Sanktionen,
Nicht mehr mit ärgern. Ist wie wenn du Veganer sagst, ey gibt kein Fleisch mehr, sagt er hey das mache ich seit 30 Jahren. Was willst du von mir? Ähm,
aber halt ähm so ich meine in Russland ist halt auch das Problem. Theoretisch haben sie ja alles im Land oder im Großen und Ganzen, was sie brauchen. Das heißt, wenn sie ihre Industrie und alles wieder auf die Kette kriegen würden, also jetzt über lange Zeit, also nicht mal eben.
Dann können die aber auch mit den Sanktionen leben lernen, das wäre total bescheuert. Also es wäre kein kein hübsches Leben wie vorher,
Das meine ich halt, wenn sich das so ewig zieht, also mit dem Iran hieß es ja auch am Anfang, ah, das gleiche haben wir die im Sack und ähm inzwischen sind die Enkel von denen, die das gesagt haben am Drücker und sagen immer noch das Gleiche.
Schwierig in welche Richtung das geht und nur weil's völlig bescheuert wäre so zu leben ich meine guck dir Nordkorea an,
Wenn man sagen würde, Kim Jong-un, du kriegst ähm du kriegst eine Milliarde und eine eigene Insel vor Hawaii und du wirst nicht strafverfolgt.
Und dafür gehst du aus dem Land raus und das wird irgendwie offen. Wer allen geholfen und trotzdem macht das nicht,
Ähm also so also so nur weil etwas schlau erscheint und weil das andere dumm ist, heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass es passiert und deswegen denke ich, vielleicht erleben wir das auch echt, dass ähm das wie Nordkorea oder Iran wird mit Russland nur in groß,
die irgendwann mit den Sanktionen schlecht leben, warum auch immer, wie bescheuert auch immer.
Oder die andere Theorie war ja, dass ähm äh Putin ein Herzinfarkt oder Autounfall erleidet irgendwann,
sein Nachfolger schiebt alles auf Putin und dreht die Uhren zurück auf die Zeit davor,
Wenn er noch ein bisschen schlau wäre, gibt er auch die Krim und so zurück, weil was soll's, ist den Ärger nicht wert und dafür könntest du zurück zu deinem System mit den Oligarchen und allen geht's ein bisschen nett und das Land ist halbwegs offen,
Ähm nur Putin ist halt so abgeschirmt, dass es wahrscheinlich keinen, also zum einen gibt's keine Nummer zwei, die es machen könnte, also da gibt's ja die Nummer zehn oder so vielleicht in der Hierarchie und zwei bis neun fehlen.
Ähm und zum anderen, wer soll ihn umlegen, weil er sein Apparat schön zugezogen hat. Nur das denke ich auch so und alle, also,
Für die Welt am einfachsten, er kriegt den Herzinfarkt und danach,
Rückende dreht die Uhren zurück und alle sagen, ach mit den ganzen Oligarchen und den Menschenrechtsverletzungen da. Ah, das war gar nicht so schlimm, wie wir dachten oder so, dass alle auf einmal das für okay finden, dass es wieder alles das Gas ist billig und der Luftraum ist offen und so.
Aber ich meine es gibt so viele Varianten wo man sagt na ja die einen sind unrealistisch und die anderen sind dumm aber irgendwie wo wo landen wir am Ende.
Was ja auch noch für Putin so eine Perspektive sein könnte oder zumindest derzeit vielleicht auch sogar noch äh ist, ist ja sein.
Anderer Wirtschaftsverbund, die Brik oder Bricks äh Staat mit Brick haben sie mal angefangen, dann kam noch Südafrika dazu, also Brasilien, Russland, Indien, China, Südafrika, deswegen heißt es so, dass er auch mittlerweile ein.
Die Achse des Bösen.
Ein ein schräger Club geworden, ne? Also Bolsonaro in.
Ungarn fehlt. Brixuk.
Vielleicht könnten die,
können die sich demnächst äh äh bewerben, wenn's dann mit der EU Mitgliedschaft nicht mehr so funktioniert. Aber da sind wir, glaube ich, noch relativ weit weg, äh aber man hat immer so den Eindruck, dass wir dem Orban äh.
Mir scheint er er sagt.
Na ja, der will ja der will, der will ja, der will ja die EU melken sozusagen, ne.
Ja ja genau. Das ist so ach das ist wie die Leute, die alle in Deutschland leben und sagen, wie doof sie ist. Sagt man, dann geh doch. Du hast einen der besten Pässe der Welt, die Welt steht dir offen, nie. Eigentlich das nicht, dableiben und meckern.
Park Querdenker sind jetzt in Paraguay. Die haben's geschafft.
Mhm, ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg, genau.
Ich war mal in Paraguay, na ja.
Ich könnte mir auch was Schöneres vorstellen. Aber bleiben wir doch mal so bei Bricks, vielleicht Brasilien, spielt erstmal nicht so eine Rolle, aber mit China und vor allem mit,
Indien, das ist für mich ja noch das große Fragezeichen. Auch Indien hält sich ja derzeit raus. Also die ganze Brickslinie, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Diskussion in Südafrika ist, da spielt jetzt nicht so eine große Rolle, aber ich meine Indien, eine Milliarde Menschen.
China, noch eine.
Eine, genau, aber Indien vor allem auch noch mal so, dass nächste große Ding, so nach äh China, ist es absehbar, dass
Indien wirtschaftlich in den nächsten zehn, 20 Jahren noch mehr
Bedeutung äh erhalten wird und von daher natürlich auch so ein bisschen Player. Ist jetzt Modi ist natürlich jetzt als Führer auch eine äh extrem schwierige äh Person. Das scheint mir so eine Achse zu sein, aus der Putin in gewisser Hinsicht noch ähm was abschöpfen könnte, weil halt theoretisch sie äh,
das Öl, die Kohle et cetera abnehmen würden.
Mhm. Was ich nur auch so komisch finde immer bei Russland, gerade im Vergleich mit den beiden. Also Russland hat jetzt mal ganz grob doppelt so viel Bevölkerung wie Deutschland,
und drei oder viermal so viel ähm Wirtschaftsleistung wie Belgien,
Also die sind kein Superlativ in keine Richtung. Also sie sie haben Atombomben und sie sind halt, ich meine,
Die Russen haben irgendwie neun von zehn Pokalen bekommen und die Amis sagen am Ende, wir haben gewonnen. Wer sich auch immer noch so ein bisschen lustig finde so
Erster im All, Erster am Orbit, erstes erster Mensch, erstes Tier, erster Ausstieg, erster Raumstation, aber gewonnen haben die Amis,
Erste, die am Mars vorbeigeflogen sind an der Venus, also die Sowjets haben damals exorbitant geilen Scheiß gemacht im All.
So, aber eigentlich ist es in keiner Richtung richtig großer Player, also bis auf so hier eine Nische, da eine Nische, dann kommt China,
Die quasi die die Werkstatt oder die Produktionsstätte der Welt sind und die ja auch,
Sagen wir mal in in Wirtschaftsfortschritt, also wie viele Menschen so aus der Armut in Mittelschicht und so kamen und,
Wie viel äh sie auf Elektroroller und Autos umgestiegen sind und ganz so viele Sachen, also solche Metriken, wo man sagt,
China schon ganz schön weit vorne in vielen Sachen, also auf ihre krude komische Art, aber wenn man sozusagen isoliert diese einzelnen Sachen rausnimmt, wo man sagt, hey
Elektromobilität, äh Strom aus Staudamm, okay mit den anderen Problemen, die entstehen. Aber China ist ein Player. Indien ist halt echt am Arsch, aber ist trotzdem ein großer Player und Russland finde ich, passt eigentlich von den Metriken,
nicht so richtig da rein, also nicht,
weder von Produktionsstandort noch von Wirtschaftsleistungen noch, also sie sind irgendwie mächtig, so ein bisschen wie so ein Influencer. Man sagt, ja ja, ich kenne den, aber welche Metrik macht ihn denn aus? Und das ist irgendwie finde ich immer so ein bisschen komisch bei Russland, dass sie,
Im Vergleich mit China eigentlich nichts sind. Also so an an vielerlei Stelle.
Ist es eigentlich nur Fläche oder sagen wir mal vielleicht mal Ausdehnung ähm ja die so geopolitisch äh bisschen was bringt plus eben Ressourcen. Es ist halt einfach Ressourcen, Ressourcen, Ressourcen und wenn du die Ressourcen abziehst, bleibt wirklich gar nix mehr übrig.
Wo ich echt denke, was müssen wir China bieten, dass sie das übernehmen und uns billiges Gas verkaufen? Ich warte drauf, bis der Erste mit so einer Idee kommt.
Ich glaube, das das wird nix.
Ich glaube, das ist ein moralisches Dilemma. Es würde mich nicht wundern, wenn wenn Trump da wäre, wenn der nicht sagen würde, komm, ich gucke weg und du nimmst die Kiste.
Okay, jetzt werden wir, kommen wir so ein bisschen auf Stammtischniveau. Mal deine Einschätzung, was denkst du, was in diesem Krieg jetzt passieren wird? Ähm was werden wir sehen in den nächsten.
Das, was du auch schon gesagt hast. Also ich denke, es wird sich extrem nach Osten, also auch,
Osten vom Donbass noch verlagern, also nicht mal unbedingt der ganze Donbass, sondern da auch so Grenznähe.
Unterm Strich, was ja irgendwie von Anfang an klar war, im Prinzip braucht äh Russland eine Verbindung zu Krim. Also im Prinzip brauchen sie eine eine Transitautobahn von.
Haben Sie doch eigentlich? Haben Sie ja.
Ja, da unten diese diese Brücke, aber ich meine.
Ja gut, aber was ist äh da ist ja alles. Da ist eine Straße, da da fährt die Eisenbahn hin. Also sie brauchen diese Verbindung nicht sehr. Äh sie hätten natürlich dann quasi das Asoci mehr äh als eigenen Teich, das äh macht natürlich schon mal eine ganze Menge äh her.
Und ähm die andere Drohung.
Auch sagen wir mal ein Wirtschaftsfaktor, den wir den wir jetzt auch gerade eben vergessen haben, ist natürlich die Sache mit dem Weizen.
Diese Gebiete sind natürlich extrem ertragreich und in Afrika äh werden's schon alle ganz äh nervös
Natürlich kann sich Russland jetzt in Afrika äh neue Einflusszonen schaffen, weil sie sagen so, ach Ukraine kann euch kein Weizen liefern. Ist ja blöd.
So ähnlich wie China halt mit mit seinen Wirtschaftsleistungen da sich eingegraben hat in in.
Aber Russland kann's halt nur mit Ressourcen und da wo es halt irgendwie mit Öl und Gas jetzt nicht funktioniert, da äh ist natürlich Weizen. Eine andere, interessante Ressource, weil es sind nun mal einfach die größten,
ergiebigsten Flächen dafür, dass absolute die Grundkammer der Welt.
Dadurch, dass sie natürlich jetzt die Ukraine auch konkret daran äh hindern, über Odessa, derzeit auch nur in irgendeiner Form etwas auszuliefern beziehungsweise durch den Krieg ja auch den kompletten,
Weizenanbau in dieser gesamten Region verhindern. Das ist natürlich schon etwas, was die Welt äh sehr bald äh spüren wird, also spätestens im Herbst.
Auch in Zukunft, wo ich denke,
Wie geht's weiter? Willst du dann militärisch gesicherte Cornfelder haben oder also äh ist ja auch so ein Ding. Also wenn man sich da jetzt nicht zeitnah einig wird,
Ähm also,
du kannst ja nicht wirtschaftlich in einem umstrittenen Gebiet, also auch in Zukunft das nicht betreiben, vor allem wenn Russland dann anfängt,
Sabotage, Trupps im Donbass oder so zu bezahlen, die hier und da mal die Kornfelder anzünden oder was auch immer. Also so mit billigen Mitteln teuren Schaden entstehen lassen. Das denke ich halt auch immer.
Das ist ähm also für für genau diese Gegend brauchst du ja eine richtig stabile, solide Lösung,
weil das kannst du nicht militärisch sozusagen sichern und militärisch beschützte Schiffskonvoi für Weizen oder so machen. Das funktioniert dann ja auch nicht.
Aber ich denke wahrscheinlich ist halt, ja also bleibt und dass sie aber halt diesen ja also Russland möchte diesen Teil und Ukraine will ihn halt nicht abgeben. Ich,
keine Idee, was mit diesem Streifen da passiert. Also ich.
Also klar, da wird sich der Konflikt drum drehen, aber ich ich hätte keine Idee, wie's ausgeht oder was da auf Dauer passiert. Weil so lange's umkämpft ist, egal wie lange das geht und wenn's jetzt Jahrzehnte geht,
Auch nicht sagen, ich baue Korn woanders an. Also dass du sagst, hey wir haben noch genug Fläche in der Sahara. Lass uns Dark Horn anbauen, funktioniert ja nicht.
Ja und meine man muss natürlich auch sehen Russland trotz seiner Größe hat natürlich äh Zugriffsprobleme.
Wenn man mal genau schaut, von wo kann Russland eigentlich seine Güter so
in die Welt bringen. Da gibt's halt zwei interessante. Der erste ist, es muss halt alles irgendwie zwischen Estland und Finnland äh durch äh an Dänemark und Schweden,
Schweden, die jetzt auch in die NATO,
äh ja dran vorbei, also über ihre Nord äh arktischen Häfen und so weiter das wird äh glaube ich äh schwierig werden,
die andere Lücke ist halt äh Istanbul. Ja, noch so ein NATO-Mitglied.
Und was man bedenken muss, die Türkei hat vor ein paar Jahren noch den russischen Kampfjet abgeschossen, also die sind da nicht zimperlich. Der in Syrien, der sozusagen einen Bogen.
Auf der Karte kaum zu sehen, so ein Zipfel von der Türkei überflogen. Nachher haben sich das Leute angeguckt und haben auch gesagt, Türkei, wie genau habt ihr den abgeschossen,
Eure Rakete muss doch in der Luft gewesen sein, bevor der überhaupt in eurem Luftraum war. Also da muss ja vorher schon jemand gerechnet haben, wie ihn genau in dem Zipfel runterholt,
also man sagt hm ja nach sozusagen internationalem Recht war das zulässig,
Aber wie lange habt ihr gerechnet, dass der Abschuss klappt, ne? Also wo man zumindest sagen muss, so die Historie zeigt, hm, Freunde sind das nicht unbedingt und die Türkei holt da halt auch mal einen runter, also wo ich denke,
Wenn hier ein russischer Kampfjet am Zipfel über Polen fliegen würde, sofort abschießen, würden die den nicht unbedingt. Also da würde die NATO sagen, ey, wenn du siehst, der fliegt eine Kurve.
Nicht sofort auf den Knopf drücken, ne? Oder zumindest würde ich davon ausgehen, dass es, sei es nur der.
Man nicht einen Dritte Weltkrieg aus Prinzip starten und die Türkei da weiß man nicht, wie die gerade drauf sind. Das scheint ja auch also bei Erdogan scheint's ja auch immer so ein bisschen zu schwanken.
Jetzt nicht so, dass er sich so zu besonders zurücknehmen würde. Ich meine, die bei Racta äh Drohne.
Die drohen gute Arbeit.
Die gute Arbeit leistet für die Ukraine und äh schon so äh Lobeshymnen geführt hat.
Die auch Nachschub kriegt die ganze Zeit, also die Mengen an Munition, die die darüber fliegen, ist nicht ohne.
Und ist halt die der beste Werbeprospekt, den den Erdogan grade hat. Also ich vermute, so sieht er's auch, dass er sagt, Leute, darf ich ihn präsentieren, wieder fünf kaputte Panzer, ihr wollt auch?
Also ich äh ich meine, das Ding ist scheiße billig im Vergleich. Es ist offensichtlich gut und dass äh wenn man sagt, ey,
Die russischen Panzer, so dass das, wo die Welt mal die große Angst vorhatte, das ist eine Messlatte.
Gut.
Enno, ich glaube an der Stelle müssen wir das mal äh beenden, weil jetzt können wir äh äh nur noch ins spekulative Feld und das wird uns dann später vorgehalten mit ihr habt aber gesagt, so und so ähm.
Ja. Aber immerhin reden sie dann über uns.
Als ob das das Wichtigste wäre. Dir wird auch immer unterstellt, du wärst doch nur so ein Selbstdarsteller, Enno. Bist du das?
Ja hier ach ich denke immer ja das das wird mir immer von Leuten vorgeworfen die auf Twitter so ein Account haben aber ich habe noch nie einem echten Leben getroffen der das meinte. Also das finde ich so lustig. Das kommt immer so aus aus gut informierten anonymen Quellen.
Also ich habe ja auch welche mit Bild, die meinen irgendwie, dass so ein widerlicher, dummer Selbstdarsteller bist, der auf Kriegsjournal macht.
Geil.
Also nö weiß ich nicht. Ähm auf machen, würde ich sagen, nee. Ich war ja da und habe drüber geschrieben. Der Rest denke ich, ach meine Güte. Ähm wir haben Meinungsfreiheit. Sollen die Leute doch machen?
Also ich denke nur mal.
Wie besessen sind die von mir, dass sie sich dazu genötigt fühlen, das der Welt mitzuteilen? Also ich hätte überhaupt keine Zeit für so was. Aber gut.
Ja, jeder wie er mag.
Ja eben. Und wie wie schon Jack Sparrow sagt, aber sie haben von mir gehört.
Mag sein, dass sich der widerlichste selbstdarstellerische Kriegsjournalist bin, aber du weißt, dass ich einer bin.
Du bist ein Selbstdarsteller. Trotzdem Enno, vielen Dank für die Ausführung, das.
Ja, ich hoffe das war auch für euch in irgendeiner Form erhellend. Wir haben einfach mal ein bisschen äh die Köpfe rauchen lassen
mal hier bisschen zu schauen, wie es denn aussieht in der Ukraine und äh ja, mal gucken, vielleicht setzen wir das ja auch nochmal fort.
Heute machen wir erstmal Schluss ich sag tschüss.
Tschüss.